two
[Music]
well well well welcome everybody it's
june 22
wednesday
you know what that means
we're off the rails
[Music]
knock it over my wife
it's me it is wednesday shots are yes
[Music]
whoa
that was intense
more intense than gunfire i would say
did you play that zach
yeah that's it i knew that was you
shredding bro
that was insane that was all me
man that tom hanks entry is is a solid
one i enjoyed listening hearing that one
you you asked for something a little
different so i uh no i appreciate that
yeah you brought you brought the
you brought the heat
that was awesome
was that like ear r word for the people
listening i knew that was that
i don't think so it's loud for me i just
want to make sure people aren't like oh
[ __ ] he previewed it for me yesterday
and it was your r word and i was like
you need to pull this way back
i'm not trying to blow people's eardrums
as well good thank you thank you guys
um so guys well there's a lot too
anyway thank you zach that was beautiful
uh there's a lot to address here
obviously it is officially summer
we are chilling
with the new background rapids
chilling at cedar rap and the bunny is
having a pina colada
i don't know if that's
bunny friendly food but it is what it is
it tastes great
oh you like it cam all right i forgot
the bunny's camera yes right
also
you guys you guys should check out the
title of today's episode man it's like
last year all over again but it's true
there is good there's good
we haven't done a drama title in a while
and there really is good
drama stuff today
we're juiced david dobrik
jeff whittick actually followed through
and is suing
daddy dobrik
wow
and james charles put out some insane
new
he he started this whole campaign to
find a best friend in the dms it's
outrageous guys we're back
oh no
so
who's uh oh thank you to taylor brands
for sponsoring today's episode thank you
dan
and um well we have a lot of really good
stuff today
to talk about
one thing it is pride month um and we
were thinking
oh what happened the link doesn't work
that you guys put in there
uh one thing we were thinking
is like what's tweet's been deleted
oh we we reposted it with the well
that's why different caption i got it
we were thinking what's the best way to
do a pride thing and
i didn't want to do something that felt
disingenuous and just you know like
happy pride or whatever you know
i don't know change the teddy fresh
thing to a rainbow flag you know i mean
come on
so we we've sought out a special story
and i think we found
wait why does it say oh yeah we sat out
a very special story
i love this
you guys heard of the homophobic dog
yep
so
here let me pull up some memes that you
guys may not know about homo
phobic
i put hobophobic that's what keemstar
says oh yes that's right homophobic dog
this shit's funny man
it's a dog
[Applause]
who hates gay people
what the hecking dog
there's this one let's hope it's just a
phase
the really famous one the origin one is
here
um the one that started it all
is this one not too fond of gay people
which i guess is supposed to be like
your aunt at dinner or something with a
glass of red wine right
but the funny story about this meme that
you guys may not know is the owner of
the dogs is a gay couple
how epic is that that's
and we teamed up with
with homophobic dog and his lovely
uh parents
so cute oh my god he looks so good in
that it's so adorable so i love the the
face really conveys a lot
and also he's white so it's just like
he's had it with anything that's not
right
that's not
to my taste damn it
oh my god but here's the this is uh the
dads
of this beautiful homophobic dog
and we wrote a little something about it
which is really small
let me try to open this up
yes so
this dog
is the homophobic dog and anyway well
basically what i said here you go
we love that so many people have come to
know and love whitney that's their dog
as much as we do after memes of her went
viral while we find most of them
hilarious we also recognize many of them
are phrases
that most of us in the lbgt plus
community have endured
while whitney has been branded the
homophobic dog homophobic
she's actually the furthest thing from
homophobic as most of her favorite
humans are queer
we thought it would be important to
celebrate pride month with whitney logan
and ben so we sent them some matching tf
sets and got these amazing amazing
photos back
happy pride night i love this photo
so there you go that was a nice little
story right yeah
i love wiener dogs i my family had
wiener dogs growing up
big fan of the dachshunds is that right
they have good personalities i've never
spent time around oh they're so cute
i've never done anything weird with my
dogs okay well no no no no no
i'm suspicious that you brought that out
of nowhere jordan
uh we posted on instagram i think
there's even more photos here because
twitter
has a limit oh i guess not but there you
have it guys that was a fun little thing
how nice is that
so happy pride moth to all of our
lgtb
lgbtq plus
keeps
and to all and everyone else too because
you know what
we gotta we gotta fight together for
people's rights inequalities and
if if cis people don't stand up and
speak out then
they need they need everyone's support
basically what i'm saying so cheers to
them
we love them folks
we love the gays
the gays are fantastic folks i'm telling
you
um
i love it last week we talked about the
remember that creeper shot of keemstar
at the theme park with his daughter
uh yes
well
and there was another photo i was trying
to find
but it was removed well the guy posted
it so now we have this and it's actually
quite good it's already spraying a lot
of memes
here it is he said
i deleted the pic of keemstar running
off the roller coaster because i didn't
want anyone to think he was running away
from me
that's actually funny as hell i didn't
even think about that there's no story
other than he got off the ride and
started running past his kids and
girlfriend
okay [ __ ] this is a powerful image man
he's running to god really look at that
big-ass cross there
keemstar does need god
that's kind of awesome in it so people
started making uh
running keemstar memes
it's got an interesting kind of body in
it
why are you so cute when you talk [ __ ] i
shouldn't talk i know my body's [ __ ]
i have the i have the body of like a
lunch lady
you see me walk from the back dude
my thighs and hips are so wide it's
insane
look at the body of the lunge lady it's
true man
you should donate your body to science
when you pass
i am an organ donor well there you go
good good
i've heard horror stories of people that
donate their body to science and then
they just end up like
doing like insane [ __ ] with the body
that's not scientific at all have you
heard those stories
yeah they donated to like the army for
them to shoot at it or something oh yeah
they just yeah dude oh i do
take this body and they just shoot your
[ __ ] dead body
because that's that story is about some
grandma's body being blown up or
something
yeah yeah yeah that's what i'm saying
like you think you're going to help like
you know humanity and you just your body
just gets absolutely desecrated by the
military saying what happens when you
throw a body on a grenade or something
that's still
theoretically a science experiment i
don't think what people are signing up
for i mean what happens
i don't think that's what people had in
mind yeah probably not
yeah here it is
man horrified the army blew up mom's
body after it was donated for research
i know gruesome new details have emerged
about the arizona body donation facility
that told people their loved ones would
aid medical science so there you go that
was a lie anyone here for marriage sona
they are
she was
so that's that's pretty interesting but
anyway
here's memes
of him running and
taking off on our subreddit god bless
him when ethan mentions keemstar on the
pod this is so true he's running into
that youtube headquarters
and i just think it's so funny that he
somehow has created this
this theory about me that i'm like in
with youtube like bro you complain to
them every [ __ ] time something
happens i mean you're running in their
headquarters
there was more when there
oh that was the best one
yeah i saw one about drinking in the
something about id
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
um
so much keemstar stuff at the top of the
show but it's pretty good i just sent it
pov keem asks
if you want a drink but he notices they
accepted your idea
right because they that that would mean
they're too old for him correct yeah
yeah he's audi
terrorist
yeah
he's leaving the bar quickly that's what
that shows
to find someone younger
right it's like a romeo juliet
but um
speaking of keemstar
let's do this at the end of the show who
gives a [ __ ] about keemstar nobody cares
i do want to talk about that but at the
end you know what i mean
it's just him crying about ninja got his
g fuel thing and i mean it's great don't
get me wrong but
we don't need to talk about that now
um
you so i was on howie uh mandel's show i
guess i'll talk about that mm-hmm
howie mandel
deal no deal guy
america's got talent bobby's world
bobby's world i always associated with
apparently apparently howie
is famous for
putting a glove over his head did you
know that
i did not we learned that yesterday we
looked it up after we were watching the
podcast this is this is what made him
famous is he what he i guess is the
first person to do this
and he would do this on stage
and it killed
howie mandel fits like a glove
vinyl record
what do you think
um not exactly cutting edge stuff well
today but then it blew everyone's mind
yeah nobody nobody would have dared to
put a glove on his head
yeah so that's
actually an important kind of change in
human trajectory i feel like
it's very odd
anyway it was kind of funny because i
ran into him
i was with ela and the kids and we were
just having a nice day on the weekend
down at malibu
and um
we were at the playground i was like oh
that's howie mandel he was sitting
across from us i didn't say anything
though it's just kind of funny
seeing him there by the way i see a ton
of celebrities down in that malibu ball
i saw jerry seinfeld there
that would that blew my [ __ ] mind
stop laughing it's not funny i'm not
laughing i'm saying nice things jerry
i think that's the only celebrity i've
seen by the way where i went up and said
like uh
hey i'm a big fan
oh you did that yeah simp
sam but you know what's the point he
gets that all the time everybody loves
jerry seinfeld was that i had to say
something was he called you or was he a
dude no he was super nice he was super
nice he was nice to everyone he was just
chilling
they they drive their cars he's in like
a car club he's like one of these car
guys well you know from that show yeah
comedians and cars but they meet on the
weekends in malibu and they all bring
their like
psychotic insane super expensive
collector cars
and show them off to each other so it's
like a whole thing
but yeah he was nice it was just cool
crazy to see him in person i mean i love
hit the show seinfeld was kind of a
formative
show for me
um
and hilo too
but anyway i saw howie there
and we started walking back to the car
we were time to go
and him and his daughter like i'm gonna
he stalked us bro he followed us to our
car
he goes ethan i go oh [ __ ] what's up
howie
and anyway we talked a little bit him
and his daughter have a podcast
and they invited uh me to go on
now i i usually don't do other people's
shows just because
one i'm busy i'm super busy right i mean
we do we're working here all week
and when i'm not working here all week
doing four shows i'm with the family i
generally don't
don't do other people's podcasts but
everyone convinced me that
i should do it because how is
a legend right
um
he is by the way
let's pull up his podcast
howie
mandel does stuff is the name
of his podcast
he's just sitting but he does he do
stuff
also i got i just gotta i gotta laugh a
little bit howie
his icon is him backwards with glasses
now
now if you're famous you should show
your face right it's just right i mean
that could be anyone
same with his thumbnails too he only
shows that face in the thumbnails and
it's triggering it's just a little odd
i'm gonna but i love that for him i mean
you know god bless it
for some reason like i still think i
would have known that like it looks like
the same thing like yeah i mean he's got
a recognizable dome he really does but
i'm just saying this reminds me more of
like you don't know jack or something
it's like a bald man silhouette yeah but
just turn around let's see that
beautiful face that you spent your life
making famous you know what i mean
decades of work smile
let's see his smile dang i feel like
he's the epitome of the bald man though
no offense dan
but he's just when you think bald dare
you howie mendel well you know what's
interesting he actually isn't
bald he shaves his dome because he has
he's like a germaphobe and he feels
cleaner when he's
totally
hairless i see he does bald well so he
owns that [ __ ]
[Music]
but yeah that's what i do too
we love that for you dan
and listen i'm not gonna be
my god how much do i say
what do you mean without looking like an
[ __ ] i could i could say some stuff
okay go ahead baby you lead i noticed
there's a lot of views on the episode
with you
thank you abe for noticing that compared
to the other
guests i wonder what that is thanks
avery for saying that
but one thing i noticed is like his last
episode had like
4 000 views after a week yeah and i was
like listen
i love howie and stuff but i just i
don't know i got to go there i've spent
a whole day doing this podcast for 4 000
people to watch it i just i don't know
yeah
so there was like a whole thing but
everyone was like dude it's how we so i
said okay i'll [ __ ] do it i'll do the
thing
so i drove over to his place
also if i may know go ahead third most
viewed
uh video is that right after one day or
one day well that's nice
it's nice that the food troopers care i
didn't promote it at all and the reason
being that i didn't
and howie i love oh my god how much do i
say
i gotta say every time i see that
thumbnail this is kind of an aside that
photo in the middle of you
yeah it's a drawing right no i keep
thinking it's tim poole
oh interesting let's look at that
let's not bring that up yeah
sorry to say isn't that the internalized
oppression yeah yeah i look so different
then 50 pounds
i'm sorry i'm going to get pissed off
about that yeah yeah and neither of us
want to look like the other one so let's
just leave that out
but the reason is is that the title was
uh something like ethan klein of h3
speaks on current relationship
with trisha paytas in the return of
frenemies
and he was like you can't tweet that
because they had to go for the title you
know the juice
so um okay but anyway here i'm talking
promoting it now aren't i
it was a banger app i got to say thank
you bro you you really made it very
entertaining thank you so much bro yeah
we were cracking up we put it on here
we were we were i'm so glad i was really
nervous about this to be honest so
anyway i went out to
the i went out to where he records
he's got a massive studio dude i was
expecting
uh i don't know what i was just
expecting like a little one studio he
has his own production company and
there's like a huge massive studio it's
like 30 000 square feet or something
damn
all kinds of stuff right there i mean
yeah he's
he's the host of
america's got talent yeah they record a
lot of the stuff there oh really he
produces a lot of the stuff there
he also has this really cool
he showed me this insane thing he's
invested in there and they're
headquartered out of his office
god was it called i can't remember the
name
but it's like a hologram thing where you
stand in like a booth
and it like
shows your image anywhere in the world
and the quality is like insane
so you can have like a full body
interactive thing with people
i forget
right in this booth but it looks amazing
so
it's probably the tech has probably
evolved since i did this but i actually
did that a couple times uh helped
engineer doing that in fact i did it for
eric andre uh years ago this was in like
2015 or 2016 where we had him in a
studio here in la and we projected him
as a hologram to oh wow this event in
toronto oh yeah so it's one of those but
like i'm saying it looks so good so
it was really cool um that was cool yeah
that's a
but you know it's funny because i i was
like all right here we go this is going
to be the most produced show ever for 4
000 views because you know it's like
howie and he everything got it's got to
look good he's famous sure so he has
this podcast with his daughter there's
like 20 people there working you know
it's like a huge uh production dude here
let me pull this video up because it's
pretty funny yeah we have some time
stamps on the dock oh yeah personal
favorites
let's see
so here i'll hit those up next but let
me just click the video you guys can see
but the studio is like insanely produced
they have this massive command station
back there with like 20 people
right yeah you saw it in the in the show
a couple times they showed their control
and the biggest [ __ ] screen i've ever
seen they don't show it but i'm facing
out like that and before me is literally
like a 20 by 20 foot this was probably a
million dollar
one of those epic [ __ ] full hd
screens you know can we get some of
those
out of my budget probably i don't have
highway money [ __ ]
you're big enough love as it is i said
you love bots
new love bot that would be so funny no
but seriously if we did a love bots it
would be like the size of that whole
back curve which would be pretty funny
let's be honest
that would be a funny way to spend money
that would top the scorpion chair i
would maybe just gonna lose it let's
actually look into how much that would
cost
i'll look into it but it wouldn't be a
million but i yeah hundreds of thousands
probably
if it was completely behind me at that
point i just given to the meme at that
point yeah okay with that
just loves face dominating every crew
shot
i think it would suck the light out of
every shot though and everything well
everything we would be backlit heavily
because it would be a giant scream
behind all of us
sorry love it doesn't make too much
logistical sense
we'll look into it okay but you know
what's funny every time he pulled
something up on the tv my face gets like
blown the [ __ ] out with light right yeah
that's that's so bright
speaking of looking like a lunch lady
you can really appreciate how bizarre my
body is in this
they show my full body at some point you
got to see how [ __ ]
putrid i am i mean i i don't i'm not
going to [ __ ] on myself because people
get uncomfortable when i do that but
let's just say
you look fine my body looks crazy dude
what i will say oh yeah
oh there you go he just sent uh oh you
got me you got me still thanks bro it's
not that bad it's not bad
wait did someone edit my head to make it
look small
or something dude that ain't dirt that
doesn't make any sense beautiful you
also do sit in like crazy positions
right i remember when i started working
here and i watched you and i i could
like see it all i was like oh this is
like different
because i can see what his people are
doing beautiful yeah like they just play
around i feel like that's true they're
they're wiggling right now here i sent a
better one
let's see thank you uh a.b
what the [ __ ] dude that is such an
insane shot
that is such an insane shot beautiful
what
am i right dan i mean
tell me this is tell me i'm this is an
insane shot
for just
i mean the whole thing are you are you
sure you're not shrunk in that one yeah
i don't know you're you're dead i
literally don't know
i think these have been uh manipulated a
little bit
why are they doing this what does this
mean
but you know your fans to post the real
screenshot on reddit yeah please if
somebody uh could dig that up and post
that to reddit yeah but actually i was
watching the new obi wan super
interesting
homage to uh
howie in the finale oh that was the
surprise cameo yeah i don't remember
this thing oh wait this is from this is
from obi-wan the newest episode just
dropped out she appeared with the glove
on her head wow
this character to come back
there's a hunger
well this character so is this one
shrunk or not yeah
is my head shrunk
my body's weird enough i don't need you
guys [ __ ] with my proportion the fact
we don't know is
kind of killing me the proportions in
this photo
are off
i don't necessarily know if it's because
someone edited it or because
the camera did it welcome to my world
dude this is what i go through every day
are you comfortable sitting like that
well it wasn't it was fine but okay now
something's going on here
what is going on here you have little
leprechaun feet
huge am i like 30 feet away from howie
yeah i mean that was kind of what i was
wondering is if it's just a trick of
perspective that you're
significantly
further back than it seems
you look like a hobbit dude yeah i don't
know i don't know if it's edited or not
it was a whole weird situation there
yeah so anyway there's there i was
there i was holy [ __ ] it's it's not an
edit
i found the exact way he looks even
smaller in that one
show it's definitely the wide lens if
you go 11 seconds into the video 11
seconds okay let's watch it
go to the store that just trippy room
with everyone aren't you or at least it
seems like it's yes yeah that we do
we're all in the same way
go get string
you can get string cheese
by the way i have a pet peeve when
people start recording they don't tell
me i just i hate when people do that oh
yeah that sorry howie you know i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna speak my mind but
you guys are great you guys are lovely
and uh but you know
they do that i've that's happened before
when i do podcasts
and it's like you gotta tell me when
we're recording you got to give me a
countdown or something
okay
finally we got an accurate one okay this
one this one actually looks fish this
one looks really fishy
right no i think that one's actually
that's pulled straight from the episode
there's no way that's real you guys no i
think that's that's it that feels true
to me yeah that's true to you guys it's
proportional again it's a forced
perspective thing to an extent but it
looks [ __ ] up to me but okay if you
guys say so beautiful beautiful
do you want string cheese we're talking
about string cheese and stuff which is
like
pretty compelling stuff to open the
podcast to if i'm being honest because
you know on youtube you want to capture
their attention immediately i kind of
like the little the the
behind-the-scenes vibe of the opening
well that's really kind of conflicts
with how the podcast is sort of run
because if you're doing that for like an
authentic sort of vibe
but then you're not able to say anything
the whole time it kind of sets it off a
little bit you're saying they're trying
to be authentic in the beginning but he
was
very nervous about it in the show
okay with peace and love of course
go get string chief go get a string you
can get string cheese
do you want string cheese do you like it
i mean there's too much with the string
cheese
cheese you want string cheese i have
plenty of i consume a lot of string
cheese at home with my yogurt it's not
an edit it's one of my staple snacks but
i'm good we have a lot here i like
string cheese these people yeah we get
it with the string cheese but anyway
yeah that's real so there you have it
this is straight from the uh
the camel's sphincter as they say
they did give me an arrowhead water by
the way which is
um natural spring water martin approved
yeah i got the just quick side i got the
shower head filter thing did you stalled
it yeah last night it's [ __ ] great oh
i bought it i haven't got it in yet i
have one as well so how long have you
had yours dan
i guess like a week now so do you feel a
difference yeah so i don't know if
everyone will feel a difference
with mine i feel like i definitely do
because in the building i live in um
they don't seem to have a
soft water filtration thing or whatever
those are called i don't think most
people have that
right and so well i don't know it's just
it's always been the water
in my building is like particularly uh
harsh gotcha and so um i noticed a
pretty immediate difference with it but
if you already have soft water i i don't
know if you would necessarily notice it
but i agree with you dan it it's uh it's
kind of night and day
for me so because martin said it
immediately improved his skin and hair
quality because there's no chlorine
right where are you feeling that well i
only have 50 of those things so how's
your head a lot of body hair so and it
feels great well zach you've got a ton
of hair you notice yeah
well i to be fair i've only had it a day
but i could tell it wasn't so
it didn't feel so grainy if that makes
sense yeah that's not yeah oh and that's
that's that's great martin that guy is
he's such a legend he really opened our
minds but also fair warning and i didn't
listen to dan on this i'm like ah how
bad can it be when you install the thing
there's like because it's a charcoal
filter you didn't listen i didn't listen
to you so
you run like two minutes of water
through it before you can like use it
this [ __ ] like black charcoal [ __ ]
just goes spewing all over it's just
like black [ __ ] when you first turn it
on oh really just for a second yeah
cause just like have you ever had like
the brita filtering they tell you you
have to like soak it for a while before
you actually oh i didn't know that i
didn't know that
either just use it supposed to suck
though
uh
sorry i forgot my head
oh yeah you're supposed to run cold
water through it for a few minutes and
yeah when you initially flip it on
it like bursts out and they tell you in
the instructions put a bucket under it
to like catch that and open put in a
bucket yeah and i was like that was what
i said and then it just [ __ ] they
were right
it was [ __ ] got everywhere
it sprung out of the shower god it was
wild
interesting well this one looks odd to
me and guys you can't tell me this one's
not edited you see
oh that's not
no i think that's legit i think that's
it that's [ __ ] i think howie is
edited in that one
oh thank you they made it bigger yeah
maybe that's what it is that's what's
going on yeah so but this is the real
one
that must have been a comfortable couch
though right it was
fine
but yeah the but look at this
perspective now this is kind of an
insane shot right dan back me up here
this is sorry go ahead uh
well i would have i mean they obviously
have it framed for if they have multiple
guests on that couch probably should
let's get a second cam in there bro this
is like so unflattering look at what a
[ __ ]
lunch ass lady looking as [ __ ]
look at me dude amy go ahead you're
gonna be more critical i like that about
you well can i be critical of one thing
here oh i'm going to like it though
because you know i'm in it um
no i i'm liking because i love that the
podcast and the framing
every time you wear that shirt
i think it's because of your like salt
and pepper hair
um
also having like a black and white shirt
it just makes you seem like
like naturally desaturated like even to
the naked eye it's like you're just
you're you're like a
black and white cartoon all of a sudden
that's interesting you think it [ __ ] up
the white balance maybe i mean don't you
look just kind of like
yes zombie-ish yeah
for sure you've worn that shirt on this
sucking down water like it's the [ __ ]
first drink i've had in weeks
my legs are going all crazy pointing in
different damn directions that was your
choice
i don't know people were looking at my
legs
so anyway we get down we get in the show
and
they immediately started here let me
pull this up what was funny to me people
said i bill bird them which is kind of
funny i think maybe it was a light it
wasn't as bad as a bill burr but it was
a light bell bearing maybe playful with
it it wasn't
um
[Laughter]
very different dynamic too yeah i mean i
i get why people are saying that but it
wasn't really like that
can you guys not mention bill burr
please i get ptsd every time
it takes me back to a dark time in my
life
yeah actually bill burr was on the show
we should watch that one and see how is
it
but immediately out of the gate
they hit start hitting me with the what
tell me about why you're so
controversial
and it felt like i was being like kind
of uh
interrupted grilled a little bit
interrogated yeah so but but here let me
play a bit of it
my kids don't eat string cheese you have
a headset if you want
okay you'll be able to hear us without
it but maybe if they if they speak
no or you don't have to no i'm not no
i'm not like you know a pro i'm listen
i'm not gonna say i'm the best podcaster
in the world i am number 12 actually
but i ca you know that's a
being overly critical
i usually don't wear it you don't have
to well you're in like the room with
everyone i didn't even know where it
seems like it's yes yeah that we we
we're all in the same room
i find it odd oh okay
how far into the video are you 48
seconds yeah and we've talked about
string cheese
and you hear yourself yeah if you should
wear headphones or not you should wear
headphones with peace and love i grew up
watching howie you know
we love howie we love how we if i give
some friendly advice yeah yeah yeah
start off with you know something strong
have the cameras already adjusted you
want to start off strong zach hit me
with that off the rails intro that's
unlistenable [ __ ]
our strategy howie that i think you
could learn from is lose as many people
as possible as quick as possible that
are on in on this very obscure inside
joke
oh no
yeah just let's not go that's the taste
yeah
um
let's see
yeah you don't like to hear yourself
no
ethan klein is here uh this is so then
he said that i was like oh my god we're
we're doing one of those huh okay
you know howie mandel does stuff i'm
howie mandel i'm jacqueline schultz
ethan klein
my face was kind of locked you were like
wait oh okay okay i guess we're starting
yeah that's that was exactly that face i
find it off oh okay
you find it odd to wear i'm just not
used to hearing myself
you hear yourself yeah you don't like to
hear yourself
no ethan kline is here uh this is howie
mandel does stuff i'm howie mandel
where am i what's going on where's my
camera that's basically i was trying to
orient myself
i didn't know we were live so i was
trying to find my camera and stuff ethan
klein is probably one of the um
i think
you've got some of the biggest
as far as podcasts go are you ranked
12
oh in the usa for podcast or youtube
yeah yes yeah well they started doing
the edison
um let me skip forward to where
he starts asking me about my
controversies which happens pretty
quickly
into the show
uh yeah so
i started saying like you know b word b
word the nra like i got a billion times
because it was making him super
uncomfortable
and it says banned yeah here oh yeah i
got recently suspended i said
jokingly
that you know somebody should bomb the
nra and now how do you tell me what's
wrong with saying that
because you're uh honestly what's wrong
with that there's nothing what's wrong
with that
are you kidding me no i'd like that now
i'm scared to say what's wrong with that
because you have followers
i was joking i was talking about the
recent mass shootings no i get it i get
what you're saying but and then you know
it i kind of blurted it out we rolled it
back and there was like a whole
conservative kickback where like alex
jones and don jr and everyone was you
know parading me around as a domestic
terrorist or something so youtube had to
do something and we got suspended for a
week am i going to be in trouble that
you just said it on my podcast what the
nra again
stop saying that here's
i said that one he didn't find funny at
all
i love saying that b word the white
house because it's so outrageous right
actually love can you pull up that clip
uh that was really funny that the one
that you pulled up i mean i get why he's
uncomfortable
yeah
he's a dealer no deal guy he's not used
to
to bomb threats
hilarious bomb threats bee threats they
bleeped yeah b threat they bleeped the
word trump they said donald bleep
because i'm guessing because he's kicked
off youtube they assumed they would get
in trouble for saying his name
that's so odd or they might just think
they get demonetized automatically yes
saying saying trump i don't know that's
like baltimore so
wait is this oh yeah he's a network tv
guy he comes you know
his whole like mindset is very safe
content so you don't know my interject
sure
i do not think we should play this i
just want to let that oh i said i said
you don't think so no it's uncensored
okay whatever i have all those like bad
clips from my age out of context days
that i can't use anymore
because i'm scared
anyway i it's just said i just said b
word the white house
simple as that
we brought it up that's serious
but yeah anyway they keep grilling me on
this issue to you know that would be
worse oh my god no you're in trouble
you know that i'm starting to sweat i've
had you've been here for like a minute
this is you invited me on no i know
but
yeah i noticed that as well i didn't
catch that
why
i mean the trump one i can understand
there was a hard cut after you were you
were introducing who your co-host was
there was some very interesting
i wonder what happened well there was
one hard cut at the end when he was
talking to ila too
which we'll get to
maybe because his last name is pecker
packer
so wait um
i don't know why they bleeped his name
that was odd
oh people say maybe because because of
the 9 11 controversy so what happened
was
uh whatever the president that that
would be obviously no no no no
how about don't anybody nobody don't you
think that don't you think that it's
are you not somebody
would you not say nobody are you not
all kidding aside
you are you not concerned that somebody
who is a huge fan of yours that has the
exact same political leanings by the way
this is five minutes in he's being like
aren't don't you think that you might
just be inciting terrorist acts
and so i was like okay this is this
isn't what i expected but let's go i
guess right i mean after the show you
were uh
you were worried that it was like a
disaster basically when i walked out
i started texting everyone i was like
that was so off the [ __ ] rails like
they were
we immediately started talking about the
b word thing and then they they
mentioned something later about how well
why don't why aren't you banned but
other people get banned like leafy is
here i was like holy [ __ ] bro this is
crazy the way and and i understand why
you felt that way after watching it
though i don't know i i
i have a little bit
of um
more i think he's just trying to make it
interesting yeah yeah and i think you
know what i mean like i don't think
they're it wasn't malicious exactly like
it you know
it was a recent controversy it was big
news they wanted to talk about it i
think no but there was certain take my
problem was this
he hadn't watched the clip and they and
and so yeah he goes oh well you said
this thing don't you think someone's
going to go do it and i'm like well
no you have to watch this if you watch
it you'd realize yeah probably not but
anyway because it is serious i i don't
accept that accusation of like don't you
think someone's going to go
b-word the nra now it's like no of
course not i felt like you did a good
job of defending it so you know it's
just so but then the other thing that
kind of what i was like wow okay let's
do this
was uh well here let's watch this part
first zoom
might listen to it no and take if you
saw the clip you'd understand it was
like so
it was like very light and the whole
thing but don't you think that trump
does that sometimes
he's it's if if i could show you the
clip you want to watch the clip it's
banned can we watch the clip where's the
clip uh no it's on youtube you can at
one point someone in the back pulled up
like keemstar's tweet that's what i was
going to say and howie's defense when i
watched it it seemed like it wasn't his
fault but he was being fed him yeah no
no no totally yeah but they're not
malicious
he's bringing up leafy leafy that was
pretty wild right but howie mandel
doesn't know the [ __ ] leafy no he got
that intel from someone in the back but
the whole narrative seemed like it was
spun by one of those leafy fallen fan
things exactly yeah that's what i
suspected there was a fallen fan
somewhere in the back
maybe it was you know it was a fallen
fan kind of situation but no howie and
his daughter are lovely they're not
malicious at all it was an interesting
experience i mean it's it's a good watch
so
yeah we really enjoyed a good episode we
put it on in the in the studio here the
other day uh and all of us kind of were
listening to it as we worked and uh
we were cracking up it was funny that's
good i'm relieved i was i was worried
about this i really was i was like oh
god
i hope that this all
doesn't cause problems oh then the other
thing is i thought i broke the embargo
right our internet just
upside my ass
don't they guarantee that
well
we have like about five seconds so that
probably is 99. okay there you go we'll
do it live we'll do it live sorry about
that i see people saying we're back yeah
i see that uh we just had a little a
little blip on our internet there
yeah i thought you were very respectful
and you didn't i tried yeah yeah i
didn't respect one you didn't say
anything bad at all you know what's
funny howie
people were pointing this out and it's
so true because howie made a comment at
one point he's like trish is having a
baby
or i forget how he said it but it was
something i'm gonna be a mother oh she's
she's gonna be a mother yeah
and i was like how is worried about me
saying bum or b word yeah and but i was
like bro you're playing you're playing
with dark forces here
the the bo word yeah it came off but
that that's the thing howie
what abe you want to clarify i don't
want people to think i was saying that
he set off the [ __ ] because i said he
said i thought you were
oh my god av what the [ __ ] what did you
just do what are you uh here why are you
here we go again why are you acting like
that
dude [ __ ] a b
do you understand what you just did
come from you literally just started the
nuclear chain reaction that was going to
set this bomb off you just pushed it
over the edge
[Music]
i i i do not associate with that
terrible b word
i'm strong wait what happened there
though yeah just i was saying that he's
the one that actually set off the beo
word yeah yeah but i said he set off the
b
you misspoke you misspoke
you used the wrong word that's miss
speaking yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] i
i'm trying to help you
you misspoke i misspoke jesus
yeah so a b just pushed this over the
limit and now
and people are saying we'll miss you a b
love i swear to god if you make a
highlight of this [ __ ] oh yeah well
don't worry he started all the drama
channels already have clips online
you're in trouble
you're in trouble
so
but what i was joking is that howie and
his daughter are playing everyone let's
get rip a bee in the chat please guys
let's get burritos oh it's already
there's already going
can we get some burritos in the chat
please guys for a b
thank you
um
what i was saying is that they're
dealing in dark forces they don't
understand
they are asking about trisha and moses
and he's trying to get me to call trisha
he's calling ila and get trying to get
her permission to call trisha and moses
and i'm like
howie is dealing in dark arts right now
dude
don't worry about b wording the nra this
is the real bomb this is about to go off
in your life like if trisha perceives
you as sliding her
this could be the bomb that sets
everything off because if i put myself
in trish's shoes this could be the
perfect opportunity to make like a
comeback drama video like howie mandel
how dare you say
i'm not going to be a mother
oh boy
we got to get the bomb defused moses is
at home like this he's got like the full
bomb body suit you know
that they wear in war zones
cut the red wire no no no no
the blue first
the whole [ __ ] blast shield
anyway
he kind of did you dirty with the click
bait a little bit yeah and then the
click bait was oh
like you had no say in what they titled
it dan you you what were you gonna say
what you
have
no right that's kind of critique anyone
on clickbait yeah some drama yeah it's
true
i mean he he included the name
which i feel like is very that says
right it's more it's evolved explicit
i don't know it is accurate
a little bit here you're right i don't i
so you know what can you really say he
did do his job
yeah so but anyway
um
it's just i can't i i was like dude if
howie gets pulled into like trisha drama
that would be the best funniest
tournament ever
like how [ __ ] hilarious would that be
very odd very odd yes she has a direct
road in to make a video about howie
crying on her kitchen floor that is like
almost too good for her to pass up she
said she's you know theoretically
uh kind of stepped away from that sort
of content though right i mean yeah yeah
this this was in my opinion a true test
for her to see if she if she takes the
the juice well in the past i mean
knowing trisha
in the past if she was gonna make a
video it'd be made by now it would have
been made 20 minutes after that video
very true so the fact that there isn't
one by now i feel like is a good sign
that she's you know you might be around
a little bit you might be right this was
a true test and so far maybe she is
reformed you know right maybe maybe she
is
past all the drama
she's graduated from the kitchen floor
onto the
nursery
the nurse's the nursery
the nursery floor there you go
uh
we
are at 50 minutes already we should do
50 500. no [ __ ] way yes sir 50 videos
i wouldn't lie to you
what
we're at 51 we do that 51.
50 videos we have one sponsor i'm going
to thank real fast guys it's
taylor brands
starting a business is never easy but
there's a company called taylor brands
that makes it a bit easier
what is taylor brands it's an online
business builder made for freelancers
entrepreneurs side hustlers and new
business owners
it's a one-stop shop that offers
everything from high res logo design
business websites branded merchandise to
llc formation services and more it's
super easy to use you just answer a few
short questions and their automated
platform
gives you a customized business building
experience built
especially for your needs it's
affordable
secure
and holds everything you need to start a
business in one place now this is
actually great because i remember the
first time
i made a business it's so confusing and
overwhelming
you're like how do you do that how do
you make a business it's like
they don't teach that class in high
school do they
they sure don't dan and so this i think
is actually a really useful
um service
all of you listening out there will get
a 40 discount on taylor brandt's plans
just go to taylorbrands.com
h3 that's taylorbrands.com
h3 for 40 off
of taylor brands plans
so go to taylorbrands.com
h3 today and start your business thank
you new sponsor
shout out taylor brown
[Music]
okay oh well love where you at
yo love where the [ __ ] you at dude
damn son
damn
who taught you those moves okay
damn
okay love
whoa
[Music]
oh
damn
what are you doing baby oh
no no i saw it happening and i said no
no no
what the [ __ ]
what the frick maybe
i'm going to give love by amy's pushing
it today man i'm going to say it
abs the real [ __ ] hater in this
office
no no
no you are i think it's a little
different no
no amy's not a he just killed love and
he was [ __ ] hilarious
you can't pass that title dan
nice try please do that everyone please
tell me if i'm wrong
weren't you the one who destroyed the
original love bot and now you're trying
to destroy me too damn
and that's true you did kick it over
he's trying to get his fans riled up to
come at me i called him the fifa loves
fans yeah his fans he has his own little
fandom yeah they're called the fika fox
the fika [ __ ] yeah you put [ __ ] in
your fandom name love it's weird suck it
for seo
i didn't name it the figa fox oh yeah
there
they'd be horizontal i call them the
fika
ficus
fecal foxes
eco-photographers
yeah
guys uh also teddyfish.com you know what
it is
support your
local skyrim merchants
i'm playing skyrim
this is not just a color block hoodie
with beautiful colors it's actually
reverse fleece
which is a super cool technique where
you do the back side of the fleece so
you get this really interesting texture
on it looks great and brown and black
and so much more at teddyfish.com
actually you know this one's really cool
this suit is amazing you can't really
tell again
because it has these really incredible
details and it looks so good these
little teddy bears embossed on it
and it looks so so good yeah this drop's
got some great stuff there's one piece
in particular i really like which one's
that yeah this one
oh that's dub dude how much gold does
that cost look at that
yo that belt is insane it's actually
only like 100 gold pieces
if you can believe that okay that's not
bad and
honestly you could just steal those
i could feel that and you could find my
stealth in just a second and then you
know turn around and sit and buy it from
the same person you just stole it
i love that i really love that um when
we had pet day at the office some of the
teddy fresh employees modeled in the the
new drop and uh sean taught this picture
of chantal holding priscilla oh yeah
wearing the pink uh actually let me pull
that up since you bring it up but that
that was such a fun photo shooting day
we had all the kids and dogs over
chantel on the front killing it yeah she
looks bomb
the cutest little puppy ever
oh my god
all the dogs are so nice i don't know
why that dog looks scary
but yeah the dog was so fun having all
the doggies
that's awesome look at this little
yorkie
i love your keys
yeah that was fun anyway teddyfish.com
thank you
so where were we we were talking about
um
we were talking about howie but i think
we're pretty much done with that i'm not
done with that can we okay there's one
time stamp i want to look at before we
move on okay it's at 51 45. it is so
funny i mean olivia we're dying really
yeah let me see
divorce time stamp
yep yeah oh yeah i kind of like i knew
you were i knew you were vanilla so
all right let's see what's what's all
the hubbub about oh i wanted to push it
on i'm so [ __ ] up okay you're gonna
love this oh i will yeah and don't worry
we won we won this lawsuit too google
ryan cavanaugh oh yeah we should do that
actually that's a good idea for everyone
at home because when i did it
it was number three
and i thought
i had to scroll down
and click number three
and i thought dang
for such an important website that's a
little too far down
the search result page don't you think
love
sure yeah no you you have a point here
[Music]
yeah so type rank kavanaugh into google
and then
because it's easier you don't want to
misspell the url it's very long url you
can also scan your screen right now well
not right now but in three two one okay
oh for real yeah oh does that work for
the does that help love is that does
that go to the google page or the
website you want to go to the google
page with that one there oh
it might be a direct link yeah you know
that's that that one's not gonna help
that much just because
because
i also want them to type his name so
that they can learn more there's more
resources there i got you yeah no that's
a great point going straight to the
website is just
kind of a mess but drive angry
drive angry
anyway here you go
you know he paid for the house and the
check went through
oh by the way ryan kavanagh i've learned
this was a crazy thing i started [ __ ]
talking ryan cavanaugh of course because
he's a piece of [ __ ] and how he starts
sweating you know
and apparently he knows ryan kavanagh
he bought ryan's old house or howie's
old house
right how interesting is that
yeah but that's that was probably how
long ago was that
alex how long ago did we sell that house
he probably had money then he's broke
now he's a loser
he's divorced too
or not that there's anything wrong with
that but um
i don't know why i said how many things
are you throwing out there
there's more there's more okay okay what
i was trying to say i was going to the
brad the bowl thing
yeah and i i was like oh well there's i
didn't mean to say it like that
it's pathetic he's the worst there's
that you know
the best of us get divorced
sorry
yeah that's our website does ryan
cavanaugh look like harvey weinstein oh
my dude howie was so uncomfortable with
all that it's actually usually number
one there's nothing wrong i i didn't
mean to say he got divorced uh that i
just want to roll that back
but this is the one thing so far that
you've been talking about that you want
to roll back well because there's
nothing wrong with with getting divorced
the thing i was getting at is that um
there's this guy brad the bull
who's like railing his wife but that's
not here there
look but don't they look similar and
they're both
producers they did seem to agree that
they looked and i'm saying they do look
similar so this is a public service
we're doing and it's usually what does
that have to do with anything that they
look similar i'm sure that they're
people are confused what do you mean
this is everything
it doesn't have to do with anything it
is everything
they're confusing because no longer
[Music]
yeah he was playing the straight man for
me right exactly
um
yeah here's the moment where we found
out that they knew kavakov like no i had
a lawyer i'm being sued four times by
this guy ryan cavanaugh maybe you know
because you've been in show business
enough a piece of [ __ ] that [ __ ] guy
why is he you do too why why you guys
know ryan cavanaugh yes she's dude that
guy is a great demon bro oh my god he's
suing alex
none of that alex keep that in alex how
do you know ryan kavanagh i mean
at the top level
not a you know ryan that big of a town
yeah i'm not that surprised
i had a feeling he would might know yeah
who he was but the connection was even
more yeah directly interesting than i
thought
i
he bankrupted he was the ceo of
relativity media and then i could just
go on to educate them yeah yeah
about brian cavanaugh
uh
there was one other thing oh here let's
talk let's look at the
okay
the part about trisha where i start
talking about that
um that's not time stamped uh for i
guess explicitly uh-huh yeah we don't
have to i mean we already talked about
it yeah so anyway the basically it was
it was an interesting episode
it was a little it was just a little
more contentious than i expected i don't
think they they intended for that to
happen i'm sure they didn't i think they
just wanted to have an interesting
interview and we did have one yeah i
thought it was good so
shout out to howie and the team there
and his daughter
um and uh
shout the [ __ ] out to the island man
shout out to whatever employee of
howie's is a leafy stand too by them
well at one point i asked maybe you can
find it where i go they go well what's
with your channel
you get you say all this crazy stuff and
you never get banned but other channels
get banned i said what are the channels
get banned and they i said do you have a
specific example and she goes well i do
uh leafy is here yeah i was like oh
okay this is interesting is there a
leafy fan back there
literally
literally
play that again
literally bro
he literally sounds like 15.
that's crazy that people actually
watched that well played again [ __ ]
[ __ ] i mean literally it was literally
was he 15 like when he was making videos
like he's pretty young isn't he no he
just looked like it
okay literally i feel like we're like
reviving him i feel like every time he's
mentioned yeah he's starting to come
back alive slowly well like uh
like uh
the dark like [ __ ] the more you thought
yeah
they even speak uh whatever i don't care
he can do whatever he wants he's got
nowhere to be
he's banned everywhere
yeah that's true but he can do whatever
he wants i don't give a [ __ ]
literally
i think all of his fans grew up and
moved on by now
literally
literally anyway so here is a leafy simp
in the howie studio interesting huh
but there was a channel
where
the channel that was banned
total bull so bad i just i don't i don't
at all okay abella bill that's what i'm
saying but you also have that i'd like
to call people out you guys are you
could you could call me out it's fine
i'm not calling you out howie why are
you bringing on here to call me out
you're so nice and malibu
are you [ __ ] with me yeah i'm very
sensitive don't [ __ ] with me
oh my god i'm just
i don't want you to worry about it
okay
but i think that's like i'll be honest
with you that's kind of like the
propaganda i think of some really bad
people on youtube the same people that
take like the 10 second clip and put it
on youtube wait i keep missing the
context sorry getting kicked off youtube
well i think that let's stop talking
about that joke is controversial i did i
thank you what did i do that what did i
do to warrant ah they'll say okay this
is good
and
we're gonna greenlight it and now you
know you can trust that your video is
gonna stay up and it's monetized it's
not going to get taken down
and they'll give you notes they'll say
well we're going to we're going to give
this a mature rating and they'll tell
you the notes so you can make changes
and resubmit it
so that's really good except we do our
show live so
sometimes
we do whoopsies on the live show
whoopsies yeah but they give you a
little like
the nra
but they give there's something they're
way more lacks with you than some other
no no no i mean you're still on and
you're pretty controversial what did i
do that what did i do to warrant what
you tell me no but i just won that
kicked off youtube
well i think that let's stop talking
about that joke is controversial it is
controversial yeah but i think that
there's
wait no you have to see the whole so
this i was like you know it got a little
contentious
they said why are you even allowed on
youtube and also you're dangerous
yeah at a certain point it felt like you
were in the principles i was like whoa
okay this is interesting
on text howie i think you're dangerous
[Laughter]
you're a menace to society
a lot of other channels that you've
called out too that have ended up
getting their
like channel taken down or blocked not a
lot but you are also the that that was
another thing that i noticed there's an
intervention what's going on here no i'm
not i'm i'm sorry
i hope you're not offending you no i'm
not no like i said i'll talk about
anything well that's what i'm saying but
you also had this i like to call people
out you guys are you could you could
call me out it's fine i'm not calling
you out howie why are you bringing on
here to call me out you were so nice he
was calling me out though he said i'm
dangerous
come on howie let's do this well
are you [ __ ] with me yeah i'm very
sensitive don't [ __ ] with me
oh my god i'm just
i don't want you to feel bad i just i
don't i don't at all okay oh but i think
that's like i'll be honest with you
that's kind of like the propaganda i
think of some really bad people on
youtube the same people that take like
the 10 second clip and put it on youtube
they have this like uh conspiracy theory
that i'm best friends with susan
wojcinski even though i met her once
like three years ago maybe even longer
and took a picture and that's the only
time i've met her and there's this
conspiracy theory that like oh ethan
gets away with whatever he wants and
everyone else gets banned it's just
total [ __ ] i i've gotten two strikes
i've been suspended twice uh you know
i've gotten into trouble i don't know
what else you want me to what what i
don't i don't know what people want are
they they they're pro they want more
channels to get kicked off i don't get
what's no i think what we're asking
or what we're fascinated people always
get in trouble like do you have an
example of a channel that was banned
that that you want to compare me to no
i'm more well
yes kind of okay i was talking to my
brother ahead of time and he was saying
brothers and i don't really know the
back story behind that so i'm going to
tell you ahead of time i don't have a
lot of information but he was telling me
which is always the issue right
yeah but there was a channel where some
guy was
um
making fun of or saying negative things
about a woman in her picture
i don't know if he is no he's saying no
he's saying no yeah so this guy okay
first of all that is just another guy
that have nothing to do with made like
13 videos about a girl
make calling her ugly and harassing her
and all this [ __ ] and youtube said
they they suspended his channel and he's
been in trouble a bunch of times they
thought it was egregious enough i got
nothing to do with that i don't know why
people need to compare what happened to
me
him to me it doesn't make any sense to
me i'm not and i'm not that reckless
okay like rarely you guys don't watch my
show and that's no fine
i actually do i don't know why they try
to i don't know why they insist they're
fans the first thing she did and it's
fine you don't like you don't have to
watch the show
she uh i think yeah you watch friend of
me yeah okay but like she goes she one
of the first questions she asks she's
like um
so frenemies is coming back
i was like no
yeah that was just a troll on all of her
treats well yeah but like you know it's
okay not to be familiar with though
i accept that i'm controversial but it's
not like every episode i'm saying the
nra no no that was a one-time thing
right and that's a one time
we were all kind of i was like someone
needs to the nra i i had all these
thoughts stewing in my head and that
came out and then we kind of like we're
like whoa walk that back nobody you know
we did a whole kind of bit and it was
funny and i get that i was banned but
i'm just saying i'm not always saying
the nra hallie but you realize that you
should do that because this is live i'm
probably gonna it's not live is it
because this is not live yeah because
this is not live i'm probably gonna like
and i wouldn't do that you wouldn't edit
a lot of you saying that what the nra
stop saying it
oh my god
just because it could be taken out of
context i don't know it's already been
now it's fine um
what else do you want okay sorry i'm
gonna get over this but i guess there's
some good moments here i'm enjoying
watching it back you know
um because it was definitely such a
unique uh
uh interview i don't know it just went
so sideways it was kind of fun it was
fun and crazy what was the other part
you wanted me to watch the very end
whenever they were trying to cut it off
and you're telling them don't end it oh
yeah
yeah i was i was ready to keep talking
but how we i guess they they're one hour
it's one hour guys
so he cut my ass off
oh wait why am i
more on
i'm controlling it on my computer screen
where nobody can see it
idiot
thank you
yeah yeah that's a nice that's a nice
tech you guys have there yeah so anyway
it's a phone so will you plug it in she
can hear me that's that that that you
can't take that okay so she called ela
and she's with theaters can i talk words
in my mouth then they then i said can i
talk to your sister you make me sound
like an [ __ ] when you say it like
that then i said
and
then to get some sort of just a
conversation going she can hang up on me
i will say that so this is how we
he wants us to
reconcile
one of the most epic
um he doesn't understand the gravity of
this of this fallout right yeah so he's
like
let's get him everyone on the phone
let's make up right now this is gonna
you know and obviously it was never
gonna happen and he again he doesn't
understand the forces that he's playing
with there he's in the dark arts man he
just doesn't know what he's doing
um
so that's what he's talking about hang
up on me
he could hang up and say i don't want to
talk you could say whatever i just want
to
call her and do that and it's very funny
because uh your your uh husband has been
very verbal and and uh not
confrontational but i made them very
uncomfortable he did make me really how
he has been stressed because
don't do that no but anyway he's made me
really uncomfortable and i said don't
say that he says the thing is i could
say anything i can do it i didn't say
that i'm honest no he goes i'm honest
and i own what i do i didn't say i can
do or say anything then i said can i
talk about words in my mouth then then i
said can i talk to your sister you make
me sound like an [ __ ] when you say it
like that then i said can i talk to your
sister-in-law and he said well that i
gotta ask my wife about yeah apparently
you're that's actually a good
observation by howard yes
because there we were talking about like
all this crazy [ __ ] and then the minute
he brings up trisha i was like i can't
do that i can't talk
so yeah that was on top england's off
limits that was a really funny
observation
it's a whole thing no i know but here's
the thing
okay
i give up i give up i give up thank you
for being on the podcast gila theodore
you have been wonderful and ethan you're
a treat
um don't take anything to the nra uh
ryan cavanaugh for all i know can you
take guns to the nra you're not allowed
to that's funny isn't it
yeah it's not
i'm not going to hold off yet i'm going
to don't sign the [ __ ] off
don't do it i'm doing it i have one more
thing to say say it over the music
oh [ __ ]
ryan cavanaugh is a piece of [ __ ] and
everybody [ __ ] knows it
that guy [ __ ] sucks
all right i love that
that was just fine
yeah but honestly
overall i was really nervous about it
coming out and the comments were like so
so nice and supportive
i really want to thank the fupa troopers
out there for i don't know
the comments were just so so nice and so
gracious and uh
it really made me feel like supported
and loved and you know that's not a
feeling that you get all the time
especially online especially me yeah and
uh it was it was honestly really nice so
thank you guys for
all the nice comments really really nice
it's awesome really really nice
uh so shout out to one of the weirdest
interviews i've ever done
and i don't do a lot so the i don't know
the bar is not that low
[Applause]
oh wait here let's watch this this is
howie mandel
does stuff the trailer
3 000 views that's okay
howie mandel welcome next door new
podcast do you know when we were on
lunch bring that's your boys
let's go get the giant laptop bro and
shoot his [ __ ]
ridiculous podcast this is howie mandel
does stuff oh my god
by the way his guest list is insane
he has had like
some insane guess that's why i told you
to do it
yeah
but
okay we did it yeah
there you have it folks
how he freaking mandel this man is
clouded up clouded the [ __ ] up
yeah you wanted me to promote it so so
here it is
you're definitely going to be the most
viewed by tomorrow too yeah probably
super troopers man you guys are the best
thank you guys
family family family family family
family family family
family
you know it really makes me think about
um
how deep the lore goes on this channel
when you kind of go outside and it's
like wow it's hard to explain some of
the
some of the story arcs that go on here
the tricia one is is uh
that's deep lore bro that is like you
need like a three hour documentary on
that one and they're out there trust me
they're on youtube there's like an
expanded universe for that
yeah not to mention the hvh lore going
even further back true it's pretty wild
yeah thank you guys for for being here
thank i really truly mean it it was so
nice to read that i i really was touched
and
usually when i'm when i do other
people's shows i'm always like ugh
everyone's gonna [ __ ] hate me
and um
everyone in the comments is gonna just
be like [ __ ] ethan
but luckily howie doesn't have any fans
and they're all of my fans so all the
comments were really nice
so that was a change of pace
uh
the four thousand people that how that
do watch howie's podcast all hated it
but they got drowned out
by all the lovely fans who went there so
thank you everybody
we love you howie
it's what it is
he stalked me to my car
and he got the show
i actually told him
i told him i texted him after i was like
you should probably bleep the bomb so
because i don't want you
to get a strike because of my dumb ass
so
i'm glad that they bleep the the b word
there
well okay let's move on from howie
we've got a lot of juicy gossip to talk
about
and also we have a call
from a very distinguished uh person
who's going to call in real fast now
this is a guy
that i have spoken very highly of i'm a
huge fan
should i get them uh set up yes get them
set up and i'll just set them up here
okay
yeah so you guys have seen this guy
his name is mikey and i just i'm such a
fan of him
he's such a talent
look at this
dang
this one just dropped today
[Music]
dude what the [ __ ]
his lip goes so fast when it starts
turning up
dude he is such a talent i [ __ ] love
his videos oh god
this is his uh most famous one
this is the one that started it all that
i just fell in love with 4 million likes
so this this guy's internationally
recognized
dude he gets the timing so good his face
is so [ __ ] funny
uh i absolutely love
mikey and so of course
loving him i wanted to check in
and hear from the man himself i'm sure
he has so much to say
here's another one two three million
likes so this is a big deal
for me
but it doesn't want to play
oh we got so we got him
oh yeah
we got mikey guys
and it's like it's like the [ __ ] boy
sexy eyes you know all right
so are we ready for mikey or uh i'm
getting them in right now i have more
one second yeah let's keep watch one
more
so we actually we worked really hard to
get mikey
um we went through agents and managers
and uh
coordinators
[Music]
yo the sound effect he uses called
hollywood studio
hollywood studio
sound effects 14.
that's awesome
what else is on here
they used it too
[Music]
hollywood studio is like a big um like
sound effect library like there you go
you pulled it from the from the kings
like a lot of sound designers use it as
kind of like an industry standard
[Music]
all right
[Music]
so mikey is here the legendary huge fan
mega talent
uh coming up big time
mikey
legend i love you so much you are such a
talent
hell yeah
oh
oh yeah i mean we get an audio with the
sound all right
we're not hearing you
oh yeah oh
oh [ __ ]
so
whoa dude what the [ __ ] that's how he
actually talks
yo mikey i assume it's just a bit just
to prove that this isn't a
that this is live can you put up two
fingers or something
okay yeah
so how'd you get started in all this
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa
okay interesting um
i've never heard a story like that wow
fascinating story there mikey i thought
that was great he's like well well did
you i feel like we we were asking you
about
how you do it and you said it doesn't
take you very long at all
to learn these sound effects and it's
super
super easy for you you might be some
kind you might be like a human metronome
like some kind of
rhythm savant is that possible
right thank you for that no that's yeah
for real
by the way mikey's on cameo which we
love tell me you just do the sound
effects on cameo please i'm begging
don't talk
[Laughter]
guys mikey's on cam
oh okay okay wait he's got more to say
yeah i'm sorry i want to interrupt you
yeah okay well mikey's on cameo guys uh
mikey we'll put the link in the
description but it's mikey
k8 is that right mikey mikeyk8
okay great
was there some was there some ones from
the show we wanted to uh
try out here or nah
oh
yeah we
did provide him with some uh earlier um
if uh
you wanna show those off real quick
where is this
[Music]
this should be
wow
i love this guy my you might be one of
my favorite tip talkers so i'm just
super happy to actually meet you and
every time i see you on my homepage i
get super stoked the new one you just
dropped is straight fire
cool
awesome well i'm glad
i'm glad yeah this is the new one by the
way this was so good man how do you make
your mouth go so fast yo
that's insane
straight fire mikey
88 on tick tock as well with two y's why
do you have two wides
all right i think we're having some
connection issues oh is that right
well mikey uh he's non-verbal
or no he's not he's very verbal he
doesn't
use english oh okay there you are
[Music]
whoa
bro
damn you sense that
oh [ __ ]
wow well it was really nice meeting you
too mikey is so nice and i just want to
encourage everyone to go visit mikey on
tick tock go to his cameo because he's
going to be
having i can imagine your cameos are
insane right
yeah
i have an idea maybe someone could send
you a sound effects or something for you
to
remaster for them or something like that
would you do that on cameo yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay great
all right stop trying to seduce me mikey
with that lip bite
all right well mikey thanks for checking
in it was so nice to meet you we're
gonna have to bring mikey back for like
his insight on you know
well let me ask you this mikey um
let's see well you know russia and
ukraine obviously have been uh doing
battle
and there's really no end in sight and
it's just such a tragedy
what do you think is the best way to end
this conflict
uh peacefully and you know just just
just wrap it up there with the best way
possible
huh
[Music]
right
you know this maybe those are doves
which is a a animal of peace that is
interesting yeah the insight was was was
an interesting one it was beautiful all
right mikey thank you for that yeah
we'll have to get your insight uh
when if anything else comes up
mikey uh
mikey88 guys and i just added all of his
info in the description his tick tock
handle and a link to his cameo show some
love
the greatest
the man wow
wow all right
take care mikey thank you so much
appreciate you there
how about that huh totally unexpected
that was beautiful
i really expected him to use words
but
but he didn't yeah he just why would you
have sound bites why would you have that
expectation well i don't i guess i don't
know maybe i was [ __ ] up to expect
anything else
so funny though i love his ass
all right let's move on to the juice
shall we we shall
um
oh god the james friend application you
guys
this was so bad
i just saw it this morning
uh you know how james was trying to pick
up boys and the dms of all the social
medias oh i remember
and so he in his big apology video he's
like i'm not gonna use social media for
uh dating apps anymore
because obviously as a horrible way for
james who
has shown that he's a predator my for
you page and explore page are not dating
apps right that's what he said
so like
he promised the world he says okay i'm
not gonna do this anymore
but here's the crazy thing he literally
can't help himself and that's what we
were said from the beginning he's
pathological
this man is a predator
so much so that he actually put out a
video
begging people to he he's looking for a
new best friend like yeah you know
i'm sure he's just looking for new best
friends this is
[ __ ]
james doesn't want to hang out with some
[ __ ]
basic like pleb fan or whatever you know
what i mean like james charles is a
[ __ ] clout demon from day one bro
he's not trying to hang out with any
normies i'm just being real i was a
little confused because by the end of
this he mentions finding his soul mate
yeah yeah
so here check it
go check this out guys you're going to
love it real quick even the first second
of the video james makes a noise oh yeah
and i'm voting soundbite of the year
right there man okay okay unreal man
okay interesting let's let's see
oh okay wait wait let me getchas
oh i need more spontaneous now do you
have it already oh
oh oh
that is good
right dan hates it
you don't like that dan what's wrong
with that
oh
all right let's watch this
well done
well done
your ears are trained my ears are so
used to
you're like neo you see the world in
sound bites
dude it's just such a no
oh
or maybe that was his intention i don't
know it's gold so thank you james for
that beautiful grunt
[Laughter]
oh no it'll lower it
all right all right let's watch the
[ __ ] let's watch the video
i can't get out of it
[Laughter]
all right he says i need spontaneous
friends get a load of this
goddammit why would the sound work
all right
[Laughter]
all right ready i need spontaneous
friends oh
where do i find these people all of my
friends in my life are very much like
scheduled in advance let's do next
friday at 4pm type of people which is
fine there's nothing wrong with that but
i need people that are down for
literally anything at any time you want
her to go to dinner i'm ready you want
to go to a movie which one do you want
to see you want to do an escape room
let's do two okay you want to go to the
beach at night i'll bring my bathing
suit i'll bring snacks so you can stop
and get drinks on the way you want to go
laser tagging [ __ ] i'm ready wanna go
rock climbing
thing oh you name it bro he literally
wrote submit applications like there's
nothing more natural than submitting an
application to be someone's friend yeah
absolutely that's what's up baby that's
how you do it from everywhere in my room
now uh
now i'm seeing here you have uh you had
five years of friend experience with the
jeremy now can you tell me a little bit
about that uh and and i see a gap in
friendship here of about two years can
you explain that to me oh
man
i'm there and i'm ready for a good time
where are these people
submit your applications because
oh
i'll have to pull that one too man
different version
oh
[Laughter]
really got me about this video guys is
that
he actually puts a call to action for
people to email him applications
uh-huh
and i'm going to be writing i thought
maybe he was just speaking like oh man i
wish i had friends who were down to do
anything anytime
but no he really asked people to email
him that's [ __ ] crazy and you know
you know what he's really looking for
let's be honest
he's trying
no he's not into older wrong
directors you know what he's looking for
and he's just trying to circumvent his
oh no i'm not looking for partners on
social media today so he goes no i'm
looking for a best friend
i can spend all my time with yes
do everything together with this is
insane for anyone that's his size with
his amount of following but oh yeah
specifically it's
interesting that's so true aby
like anyone in his size to put a call
out for people to come be their friend
is like michael jackson level weird and
like that's basically what michael
jackson did to little boys
[Music]
imagine a world where a known predator
is getting tons of emails from young
people around the world
who are desperate to be his friend what
the [ __ ] bro you are sick dude you are
sick you're pathological you can't help
it
it's crazy and we we called this we said
he can't help it
and um
i didn't expect that it would be this
public and this
uh soon after he got in trouble that's
something that i can't
turn off
wow that's a good that's right on the
nose
we work on that
so let's go to the next one there's a
bomb
i just checked my dms and i'm getting so
many sweet messages from you guys being
like let's hang out i'm in la let's do
this let's do this activity i love the
energy and i would love to hang out with
you guys i'm sure you're all so [ __ ]
fun
i have a really interesting thought and
maybe this is a conversation podcast in
the future because i feel like this is
not going to fit on my instagram stories
and it's like very not deep but whatever
um one thing that i like is really
interesting and frustrating about being
an influencer or a celebrity or whatever
you want to call it is it is really
really hard to meet new people and make
new friends 10 year olds
right away and the life that i live is
abnormal right it's really hard to meet
new people because you don't know what
their intentions are you don't know you
know by the way he's doing like such a
flex with his house and backyard in the
background he's clearly looking for a
[ __ ] toy
a fuckboy toy like it's so obvious bro
it's disgustingly calculated this man is
a predator bro he cannot help himself do
you understand that yeah really sad
that didn't sound genuine james you know
ela said submitting my applications
right now ela no don't do it well he's
he's not into
to whatever he's not into you so you can
submit it
hilda
so um oh no
let's continue the reason they're trying
to get close to you
and that really sucks did you just pick
his nose bro he literally just picked
his nose
i would love to meet you i'm a very
social person i love the friends that i
have but i'm always down to you know
hang out with new people and try new
things
i really wonder all the time if i was
not in this position right i was not an
influencer maybe i like i never became
an influencer after high school
i just checked my dms and i'm getting so
many by the way so i'm gonna go to the
next one obviously but you gotta realize
how he's like messages i got so many
message from you guys and i would love
to hang out with you but like obviously
i'm not i was waiting for the bug
uh uh
yeah well here let's go to the next one
i got a normal job after that because i
would have graduated last year and now
it's like living a normal life i always
think to myself
in that scenario what would my friend
group look like
what would my inner circle look like and
who have around me because i have no
idea
almost every single person in my life
now who i love dearly i'm not
complaining but are people that i have
met either on the way up or at the top
so there are other influencers or people
that i've been able to build trust with
over a very long period of time it's
very hard for me to meet new people and
to trust new people
because there's a lot of factors right
but i always think to myself in like a
different universe if my path had went a
different way would i be in a
relationship would i have a you know
amazing group of friends would i have a
best friend's soul mate that's like you
know my thing that i hang out with every
single day
but i've never met them because our path
went a different way and if so how do i
find them because i want to meet those
people i don't care if they're regular
or have zero followers like i want
amazing people amazing people in my life
like i haven't seen people in the knife
but i want more amazing baby
translation i always wonder if i wasn't
famous would i have gotten away with it
could have hooked up with these young
boys and no one know about it yeah i
mean and he's well yeah and also in
other words i'm just a long a really
long way of saying i'm trying to [ __ ]
people in the
audience again and i always wonder how
could i get away with it thank you
i can't say the application
the use of word regular sorry for
cutting off
but the word regular hanging out with
regular people i don't know something
kind of weird
yeah
it's a little
uh he's and yeah the way he talks about
himself is just so ridiculous on my way
up and when i was at the top like [ __ ]
to the top
god
i made it to the top
nobody more famous than me
by the way people always say i pour my
sodie so delicately i hate when it goes
flat but sometimes when you pour it too
fast all the carbonation goes out and
then i can't drink it cheers
cheers
i don't think james is interested in
like
famous people though because he likes
having the power and control over yeah
and that that's why he likes to eat them
young too i would mention that the
absolute youngest and hitting on
straight guys as well he gets a throw
out of that yeah
likes the thrill of the hunt
my luggage got a normal job after that
in our lives right
so that's the thing is like i would love
that but i just don't know
how to find them or if i do find them
how to like vet them and make sure that
they are actually amazing people they
can be yeah uh when we need your
application we're gonna have to do five
rounds of interviews with my lawyers
managers uh we we need to vet you
properly
i think it's time that we bro it's not
that serious dude what the [ __ ]
my dm's right now saying hey james let's
go bowling hey james let's go to the
movies and i would just be scrolling
past not having a clue in the world that
like that person was destined to be
a soul mate oh isn't that sad to think
about
i think people i've never thought about
that in my life uh frankly it's never
crossed my mind where'd that come from
where did soul mate come from
yeah i know i thought you were talking
about friends and all of a sudden he had
some soulmates some friends to go
bowling with watch some movies i mean
some rock climbing he said
play some video games escape his bedroom
or escape the room
thank you escape the room yeah wait
escape room escape the room
i just i find this whole thing
just genuinely depressing i mean here
you have a predator in plain sight on
youtube on instagram
literally telling people to email him
his young underage fans
young fans
to email him is this not insane i mean
i think he needs to go to jail i think i
think i i i don't know how to stop him
he's already committed crimes they just
didn't press charges that we know of yet
but
james needs to go to jail i'm dead
serious he's going to be youtube's
bill cosby or harvey weinstein when it
comes down to it because he can't help
himself i mean genuinely seriously you
can't just let it slide please
not this one buddy
damn you got the whole chat tree down
for
james sack oh yeah
we could call people with him
yeah the james charles escape room would
be pretty that alone would be scary as
[ __ ]
it's so sad
what do we do about james charles
i mean he's a menace to society
there you have it
that's the james scoop
i don't know if people are care or angry
or what but
it's downright disturbing
[Music]
let me look up his channel what's he up
to lately i always like to check in
little kids paint my body challenge what
the [ __ ] that ain't right
hi sisters little kids play pinned the
tail on the donkey on my body what the
[ __ ]
that is not right to be on youtube
come on man
bad
actually his views are kind of slumping
like 12 days ago 400 000
that's that's quite low eh
love that for him he's going to be
regular person real soon i mean
i
mean
yeah you won't have to have this problem
anymore buddy
just give it another year and then
you won't have to worry about it
again 400 000 is a lot right but
i have to remind you guys used to get
like 20 million views per video yeah
definitely
let's see dream closet
charles here and welcome back bro your
sweater is half off
your sweater's not on dude
is that boomer of me but like what the
[ __ ] is this look
is this boomer olivia am i being a
boomer um
this [ __ ] has got his arm out is
one of his arms straight out not in the
sleeve what did he was he putting it on
and then got distracted and forgot to
put the other half on it was certainly a
choice
to not have it on i have seen people
wear it like that but not as
a blatant like choice of presentation
you know what i mean he was too caught
up in sending a snapchat yeah he got he
got a dm from uh
a young boy and he forgot to put on his
sweater all the way exactly
[Music]
all right let's take a look at his
closet
[Music]
do you think that's copyrighted oh no
i'm saying this is the escape room
james escaping james charles closet
let me get this because i don't know
damn bro
where's the candy drawer
i wonder how much money he made from his
heyday
and all his makeup stuff
clearly he's ballin
wow he does it all
uh
he's the first ac
and my home which is crazy to think
about it feels like yesterday that i
bought this house and moved and of
course when we did i posted my full
house tour so you guys have seen this
closet beforehand obviously you guys
know i've been working on my fashion
game pretty intensely over the past
couple of years with my amazing stylist
lina i went from wearing the same
valenciaga sock shoes and adidas track
pants every single
a little bit more of an expanded fashion
forward wardrobe and in today's video i
want to take you guys along
seven bags let's see what people watch
right here it's the biggest moment what
is this i really don't have that many
like nice jewelry pieces i pretty much
wear all of them at all times and the
other ones are elsewhere but a lot of
this stuff is just like fake it's just
funny did you hear that i thought i
heard
the voice of a child screaming help yeah
i thought did you hear that i thought i
heard something weird there too what's
this wave of you know accessories i'm
going to show you guys my accessories i
swear i heard a little boy screaming
help
yeah
damn that's crazy though
what the [ __ ] was that
it's a it's like a dick dog sound
you know accessories i'm going to show
you guys my accessories drawer i keep a
lot of my costumes yeah why is this okay
[ __ ] you uh keep playing it
okay yeah but let's listen listen
now we have some products sorry lina
we have these kind of ones you hear
something
play it again obsessed with these i just
bought these in vegas a couple weeks ago
hello can you see yourself in there can
you see yourself
i hear children screaming is that what i
hear yeah i'm playing keep playing what
the hell is going on over there
that's weird hi that's you and then my
favorite pair in the interview right
there it was a little it was a moment of
quiet there maybe if i go back
we can hear it clearer
to you guys is this pair of balenciaga
runway glasses
so these glasses are metal like apollo
the bird tall all right
what is this made of anyway stupid ass i
hate that [ __ ]
these are metal sunglasses they look so
what has you got like a whole army of
kids in there i don't know sounds like a
whole gang of them it's really low but
oh chic see if you can isolate that yeah
wait let me try to find the quiet a
quiet part here this part has no sound
for videos and instagram photos
oh my god yeah i'm trying to eq it a
little bit sunflower print
interesting
oh
disturbing
that's weird
well there you have it guys
oh
james charles is still a creep
oh
check this out real quick
uh i'm on love boats i mean a creep is
doesn't even go far enough
you know
oh yo
those are the same specs yeah
i mean i know that jimmy does ball so
it's possible
they both have the um
well james charles clearly copied him
right you know the jersey outlaw is
always setting trends and i wouldn't be
surprised jimmy better or not
man they both live outside the law so it
works right yeah they're both outlaws
yeah
jimmy should apply to be his friend
yeah
sign up
by the way we have a really funny jimmy
lee thing coming up on friday that i'm
super excited about yeah it's all
wrapped right i can talk about it um
[ __ ]
i mean
there may be additional okay never mind
yeah strike that from the record
into w working progress walk out walk
that one
all right so then let's talk about
obviously the whole david dobrik jeff
whitic thing was a huge story
and david dubrick as we know
wait what's this
holy
if you pause it
he gets really close to the camera if
you pause it you can actually see in the
reflection of his glasses
there's kids in cages right behind the
camera
that is insane dude what what an
oversight so
embarrassing holy [ __ ]
oh wow
holy [ __ ] bro
wow
oops
oh no
actually i just want to say that was an
amazing one cam i love that was really
yeah clever and great
yeah
[Applause]
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] dude
it's so funny thank
you cam just sent that and he said did
you notice his sunglasses
so yeah jeff as you guys know david
dobrik uh
dubrick
took a excavator out to a
lake and without any supervision
or first aid
or permits
or any uh oversight
he slammed jeff whitak into
the excavator and almost killed him
he got brain damage
and his eyes one of his eyes is
basically
almost
non-functional he's had like i don't
know 12 surgeries or something on his
eye
and so you know jeff's this hard ass guy
he never he doesn't want to
be the snitch or sue anyone or anything
but i kept telling him dude you should
sue him this is why civil lawsuits exist
like this is the reason
this man [ __ ] your life up and it was
completely negligent
um and if you died he'd be in jail right
now i'm sure of it
so jeff actually did it tmz got i guess
does that mean that jeff sent it to tmz
that must mean that he tipped them off
or something right
yeah i'm not sure i was a little
confused where they got the info from
but
they reached out to david and didn't get
a response but i don't know where they
got but tmz reported it so i'm pretty
sure like i don't think they [ __ ] up
they're they're pretty good with this
stuff i think
david dobrik uh jeff wood excuse for
excavator stunt gone wrong claims he
almost died
um
david dobrik should not have been behind
the controls of a massive massive
excavator used in a social media stunt
gone wrong
so says a youtuber now suing the
influencer saying he's suffered serious
injuries as a result
in the lawsuit obtained by tmz he must
have given it yeah i want it where's my
copy jeff i'm gonna see that
why would your best friend uh
cut you out like that
you guys are best buds
wait what
you used to always say that you were oh
yeah oh okay yeah no we are besties
yo should i should i dm
she's pretty fast to respond
okay
let me see if he'll send me a version
go to my dms
jeffy boy
i mean it's possible that tmz just got
it uh
via the court system i'm pretty sure
they know can i monitor that [ __ ] i
think if so someone would have the
version of the lawsuit out by now
because that'd mean everyone would have
it
i suppose
right if it hasn't actually been filed
yet yeah
it seems like all the articles lead back
to tmz's reporting so i don't think it's
out or what
when you
okay when you file a lawsuit it does
become public right so
i guess it takes a couple days maybe to
go up
so but i'm still surprised it's not
viewable
well i said yo can i get a copy of the
lawsuit let's see what jeffy boys got
for me
my bestie jeffy
in the lawsuit obtained by tmz
former vlog squad member jeff whitic
says he traveled to utah lake
in the summer of 2020 with david and a
group of friends to shoot videos as part
of
dubrick's social media comeback i love
that
i just love that whole story
it was part of his big comeback
all right
whitake says the plan for one video was
to use an excavator
operated by dobrik with one hand guys
remember
because he was filming on the other shot
gotta get that shot
and let me let me ask you this which one
do you think he was more focused on
driving the excavator or getting the
shot
i think he pulled a total of brant and
just focus on the shot
no i'm gonna go ahead and say it was 50
50. nope zach's right wrong answer dan
he pulled a lebron
my point is that 50 50 is probably still
a low enough bar that is giving him way
too much credit dude but the point is is
that it should be a hundred percent of
your focus on operating the giant piece
of machinery that can kill people very
easily zack's right they pull it a
little bran
yeah of course right they say you know
they when you get like some kind of
medicine they say do not operate heavy
machinery right
they don't have that on cameras but i
guess it's self-explanatory
do not drive a car while filming on this
camera
wedding says the plan for one video was
to use the excavator
and the water including a wake board we
know all that
however when it claims dilbrick then
suggested people get
swung around by the machine that he was
operating by only only holding the rope
whittake says when it was his turn david
started to swing him around quickly
the docks claimed dobrik noticed he was
moving the excavator too fast and slowed
down abruptly causing whatick to slam
into the side of the excavator causing
him serious injury
while he doesn't list the specifics of
his injury in the lawsuit
whitic has previously discussed what
happened that day saying he almost died
he broke his foot hip tearing a ligament
in his leg shattering his skull in eight
places i didn't know it was that bad he
broke his foot and hip that's insane oh
yeah yeah because his foot was attached
to the rope right i would probably just
yeah oh my god all bad
that's brutal
he fell face first toward the water
terrific and you can't really get a more
you can't really get more injured than
that i mean that's
it's devastating that's a devastating
injury yeah i missed the mark with that
one you sure did buddy
weddick says as a result of the accident
he's suffered wage loss that's got to be
true loss of earning capacity that's got
to be true racked up hospital bills
he's suing for general negligence and
intentional tort intentional torah
he's suing for more than 10 million okay
we reached out to a rep for david so far
no word back
dude this is going to be so interesting
to follow
intentional tort
uh means intentional swords are wrongful
acts done on
purpose a person does not need to
actually mean harm but the other of the
other person ends up hurt anyways such
as a prank
that's it yeah i mean that sounds that's
right on the nose actually
it's a prank bro
david dobrik's defense in court will of
course be play that again it's a prank
bro
the most common intentional tort for
which people contact an attorney is
battery assault and trespassing so it
seems like it fits
within the um
realm
wow 10 million dude he oh to be honest
he owes jeff 10 million dollars like
let's just be real
he owes him more than 10 million dollars
for what he did to him
good for jeff
i'm glad he overcame his like uh
whole tough guy bravado and actually
just
stood up for himself the right way yeah
look i i can we just take a moment and
see how david's doing you know
that's true this news got to be really
heavy for david actually it does
betrayal yeah right i can't i feel you
know we
i hope david's all right yeah i just
hope david's all right through all these
hard times hard times
yeah just to recap it was the uh casey
neistat documentary if i'm not mistaken
that sparked
uh jeff being like [ __ ] this you know
he's gonna betray me a certain way in
this documentary which isn't true that's
true yeah i've been defending him this
whole time
you're right it was from the kc dock
which by the way
i wonder when it's going to do a full
release because most people still
haven't seen it
i hope it goes
i hope it goes to one of the big
streaming
apps that would be awesome
uh yeah it looks like it doesn't yet
have distribution which is surprising
honestly i think most of these big
networks are so burned on doing
youtubers [ __ ]
they're probably hesitant to pick it up
they've i mean every network
i don't know how people are able to
pitch
these executives are so out of touch
and these managers who pitch these shows
like the hype house and the [ __ ] the
uh with that kid had a show on netflix
what was his name um
chasing he was a vine star
oh cameron dallas yeah jason cameron
dallas i mean every time an influencer
has made a show on a traditional media
platform it's been an absolute train
wreck waste of money for them i feel
like this one is so
different from all of that though i
agree i think i think it someone should
pick this up but it seems like those
executives are really clueless like
why the [ __ ] would people want to watch
the hype house like
this documentary is obviously way better
produced well david even after all this
[ __ ] came out david had a show come out
in discovery mm-hmm yeah isn't that
crazy that's just mind-blowing like
right right right
but you know we feel for david and we
hope he's you know doing okay yeah
actually on discovery um
they have a new show coming out this
fall
james charles is touring all of his
favorite elementary schools in the
country and he's going to be
basically meeting all the kids and just
telling which one has the best
playground because you know so that's
really interesting america's best
playground is actually the name of james
charles new discovery show ladies and
gentlemen
actually discovery i just heard is
giving
they're they're giving a
g lane a show play maxwell yeah yeah my
favorite my favorite places to find
girls to traffic and it's it's really
interesting
so g lane everybody on discovery
also thank you to beezy for 10 gifted
sub appreciate you for that
keep the keep the applause coming
keep it coming thank you to psy
10 bucks do you think a guy like dobrik
but think to use mounted gopros instead
of a one-handed one-handing it incident
probably wouldn't have happened that's
true
but he's got to be in control you know
there was like there was 10
10
plus points where all of this could have
been prevented with just a
little bit of forethought totally having
a medic on standby or how about just
totally i mean was jeff even wearing a
helmet no no like how about just we're
doing something really [ __ ] crazy
maybe just throw a helmet on like it
would have still got hurt but not like
shattered his skull most likely you know
yeah if one even one precaution was
taken
of the you know multiple that should
have then yeah it could have been
prevented or like a bi like one of their
friends as a bystander that
weren't doing the
the like tricks on the excavator why why
didn't anyone say like excuse me
so according to jeff they did say let's
not do this it's too dangerous i know
that karina got off and she was like oh
my god no no it's too dangerous yeah but
but like there was an entire crowd of
people there it seemed to me
that people were nervous about it but
like i think the pro part of the problem
right is that david's power has that
whole thing where he gets people to do
[ __ ] they're not comfortable with
well he's learning a very expensive
lesson about you know actually being the
leader or you know
owner of right content
uh because you know coming from a
youtube world in a vlog world in this
very casual friends group or whatever um
and i'm not making excuse for him it's
obviously still really stupid but um i
wouldn't doubt that he
didn't really
think that way he didn't have that
mindset at all um
which if he did it's like oh if
something goes wrong it's on me because
this is my content yeah yeah yeah even
if it's somebody else that makes the
mistake you know suddenly you you start
to
think a lot more
in terms of safety 100 100 percent
by the way thank you to bz for another
tenth other ten yeah that guy's off on
fire go pz there was a few others
earlier uh brett c and
first
sorry if that's not how it's pronounced
but they both uh gifted five a piece so
thank you to you thank you my my dudes
so anyway that that's gonna be really
interesting to follow actually and i saw
emily baker was talking about it so
actually that would be cool to see her
covering that all that yeah i wonder if
she i want a public trial
yeah we should stream that that'd be
yeah for real
uh the other cool thing or not cool
crazy
[ __ ] up thing that happened
so mike matt mal by the way my okay mike
matt maljek
malek okay thank you
i mean that's how i heard them say it on
the podcast i was watching a few days
ago i think you're right matt
i always thought it was magic yeah
magelac
yeah
wait what magelac magic
you all are saying it differently mike i
don't know the answer so i'm malibu big
mike
big mikey
that's so funny because that's what you
always say zach that he [ __ ] his pants
he was right he said it on multiple
occasions that's so crazy
yes so
he talks about how he just bought a 4.1
million dollar house
and it's obviously sponsored by this
huge crypto scam
you i don't know if you guys heard about
this uh crypto thing called celsius
and it was a huge platform and the way
it worked
is that you would give them your crypto
you would lend them your crypto and they
would pay you 10
interest annually now if you know
anything about
20
are you [ __ ] serious right love
am i getting that right wasn't celsius
offering twenty percent interest on
deposit i never used cell here's some
fortunately yeah that's that's actually
important to know
because twenty percent is like
just i mean it's absurd ten percent is
obviously this game twenty isn't is
absurd too
five percent means everything five
percent is is a lot even tougher five
percent difference is astronomical it is
uh
oh maybe
okay
maybe oh on some it's so it depended on
the coin on certain coins
yeah like this one they were offering up
to eighteen point six percent it looks
like most of them are closer to ten
percent like you said so between ten and
eighteen percent still you know yeah so
if you know me if you know anything
about equity and investing
a guaranteed return of 10
is literally a scam i mean that's what
bernie madoff offered and it just
doesn't exist
there's no such thing
as a guaranteed uh return on anything
the most you'll ever see a guaranteed
return on is like maybe at max two
percent
where it's like uh trustworthy the thing
is if you put yeah you can make 10
year-over-year on the stock market but
the thing is as you guys saw now stock
market goes up and down and you can lose
40 of your net worth or whatever you've
gotten there overnight
so what these guys are offering no risk
baby it's just 10 so that's a scam right
and so celsius
had bill how much was that company worth
it was like a huge well-trusted company
and these people in crypto are just such
suckers because this is so obviously a
scam
and it got
yeah you guys want to see what what uh
banks offer
uh
just just this is just for comparison
you can get a whopping 0.09
from banks
on uh
money market accounts
as opposed to ten percent
[Applause]
banks are [ __ ] though that's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i don't know why banks are such scum
like that it could be higher wait just
in terms of how low it is yeah yeah but
your money's insured and if the bank
goes under uh you know you won't get
screwed unlike well your money's not
going to disappear which is what
happened with celsius yes correct
so yeah celsius just all of a sudden
they pause withdrawals
everybody lost their money
and so what's happened now how much did
people lose in celsius that was one of
the big reasons for the crypto crash
it was basically a whole big connect
thing all over again yeah
there's some similarities to the big
connect thing for sure
but people get keep getting and so mike
my point is
is out here shilling an obvious scam
disguised as
a cool
thing he used to buy his new house he
doesn't ever say it's sponsored
we know it's sponsored because
if you even click the link
it has a
tracking url you can see here
it says
campaign
social media campaign it's all being
tracked
so he's
definitely got some deal worked out with
the company
let's listen to this and it's just so
scummy you know because mike i just get
so [ __ ] sick of those two guys
mike and logan they they
propped themselves off as up as these
great guys
and they're open i'm just i can't
express this enough they're openly
scamming people dink doink which i
always bring up was a open [ __ ] rug
pull and now mike is doing
a total [ __ ] scam company i cannot
express
this company is gonna you're gonna lose
all your money if you put it in this
watch this growing all i had to do was
make a down payment of 1.2 million
dollars in cash and the house was mine
let me go back
wow
it's time to work because we got to go
quick and just like that i was back in
escrow and all i had to do was make a
down payment of one sorry but this is
obviously an ad just look at how he's
talking about it
should i go back further i want the
whole context 1.2 million dollars
and the house was mine there was just
one problem i didn't have 1.2 million
dollars he's on jeff's step by the way
the sidelines oh i was wondering
interesting they must use the same
studio
because yeah i know so much [ __ ]
money so now we had an issue this really
was my dream home but i didn't want to
sell the ap either because i just made
such a big deal about buying it and i
really like the furry little [ __ ]
here's where things get interesting
through some mutual friends i got
connected to a company called arcade
that specializes in nft backed loans so
the deal went like okay arcade nft
backed loans if your scam alerts aren't
tingling already
then i don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on
uh but this is great mike you are such a
dumb [ __ ] for doing this a piece of [ __ ]
you know this is a scam mic stop this
[ __ ]
this i would lock my board ape nft into
arcade's protocol they would then give
me a loan of usd coin against it i could
then convert that usd coin into american
dollars to help pay my oh why are we
even debating if it's sponsored that he
got a whole
he got a holographic infograph from them
what the [ __ ] he never even discloses
does he it's so small does he disclose
that it's a sponsored
not that i could see in the description
yeah he just says check it out so that's
illegal actually
i mean check it out with the bitly link
it kind of no why is that no no no you
have to say
explicitly that you are sponsored by
them
and actually you have to tell youtube
too
bro there's that check box in the back
end this video is sponsored uh
is there a way to see if that is on no
if he did it would say it here it would
say this is a sponsored video right like
on all of our broadcasts
you'll see underneath it says this
podcast is sponsored content
what's epic about that link too if you
click on it it says campaign oh he
pointed it out oh yeah i'm sorry you
were like i love when you do that
i'm sorry it's because i'm listening to
other stuff it's not that i'm not i know
i know i'm screaming you're in the zone
you're in the zone you're digging
and then people go oh
but it is funny when you do that
hilarious
i literally just said that like a minute
ago
but yeah he's in the trenches guys he's
the best
thank you we love abe thank you we love
baby he works zazardo thank you
thank you very much
why does mike's voice sound like he was
mike's voice
sounds like he
i got a bad feeling about this for some
reason what [ __ ] is no just where you're
going with this you don't like where i'm
going i
i don't know where you're going
i'll tell you what it's let's let's ride
it out let's find out mike's voice
sounds like he was throat [ __ ] see i i
i
i'm by a [ __ ]
crackhead
with like late stage genital herpes or
it also sounds like a man that shits his
gym shorts at a 24 hour fitness
that's what that sounds like yep throw
that in there too
but you guys know what i'm saying when
it go you've seen those in sex ed the
late stays stds where they just look
like
they don't look foul it looks like a
lion's mane and it's like
it's just insane so
it's like what happened to your voice
bro did you get throat [ __ ] by late
stage herpes
yeah i think i might have [ __ ] in my
pants
anyway back to the scam
my down payment on my traditional
mortgage it would hold on to my nft
until i was able to repay the loan and
then i would get the eight back this was
perfect and just like that the problem
was solved and i was about to be the
first person to ever leverage an nft to
buy a [ __ ] house they were about to
make the transfer
when the unimaginable happened bitcoin
is down more than 50 percent from the
highest investors getting jolted by
volatility rippling through the crypto
world crypto obviously right now getting
crushed [ __ ] who is throwing all
these [ __ ] curveballs so yeah the
crypto and nft market [ __ ] the [ __ ]
bed but because apes were such a strong
project i was still able to make the
loan happen so again this is all part of
the script i feel like
to be like
what are they trying to do are they
trying to steal people's apes
but he's like yo but just because the
mark this is the way of the clever
marketing way of saying just because the
market [ __ ] doesn't mean you can't still
give do this deal yeah um
to be honest their business model is
even more baffling than something like
celsius because celsius
you know
they
basically you deposit your money in
there and they promise you this interest
and then
they take that money and they
trade with it they get the money
right like you give them your money and
then while it's locked with them and
they're paying you interest on it
they're then taking that block of money
and
betting on the market with it to try and
make more money and that's how they
theoretically pay out the dividends
which works fine when everything is
going up but then ponzi scheme right but
then the market crashes and all of a
sudden they don't have the money to pay
out uh all that stuff and
people want to withdraw their money they
don't have it because it's tied up in
their
investments that all like even though it
it's it's
scummy makes sense to me this thing that
he's describing you lock and you give
them your board
your [ __ ] stupid monkey jpeg and they
give you a pile of cash
and then you pay it back over a year or
whatever something is fishy are they
making money off of a board eight like
you can't
that's not divisible somebody said
coffeezilla made a video about them that
could be interesting to watch
yeah i agree it makes no sense there's
got to be something in there where like
because it's crypto too i wonder what
kind of contract you sign because
in reality you guys got scared by the
way we got some great donations holy
[ __ ] somebody did thank you two stocks
go down
i can't read your whole name but i'm
sure it's funny gifted 20 subs thank you
so much little subs and somebody also
donated 100 bucks vandal vandal said
thank you buddy i did some fan art of
ethan up on my instagram you want to
pull that up at vandal check it out
it's just like
let me guys pull that up just
yeah but
obviously the whole thing is fishy as
[ __ ] it's it's not making any sense oh
that's pretty cool that's me dreaming of
b-wording
buildings
nice
thank you
oh another 20 gifted another 20. from
stocks go down uh i wish i could see the
whole name memberships go up remembers
go up oh hell yeah
that way that's the other stocks go down
members go up woo
so anyway i'm just trying to figure out
yeah what's the business model here
he's the first pers
[Music]
let's just keep watching dumbass mike
and so i had the ape appraised at
today's value and was able to pull a 200
000 usdc loan against it which was
enough to scrape together the 1.2
million down payment to secure my
mortgage and the keys to my dream home
and that leads us to today you are now
looking at the very first half so that
was probably the end of the sponsored
read right yeah the remainder of the
video is him showing off the house and
stuff so yeah that's that's the gist of
it but yeah what probably happened is
they just paid him 200 000 for that spot
right
or more i don't know yeah who knows
let's go to the website
um so it's arcade.xyz
are you checking out coffee's uh video
on it how long ago did he make that
video so this from four days ago yeah oh
okay yeah you know this is about celsius
oh
yeah we knew about the whole celsius yes
celsius is really interesting i mean
it's just a catastrophic loss and i feel
bad for people i don't know how long
it's going to take for people in the
crypto space to realize they're just
being scammed by everybody
well
i think a lot of people are realizing it
now celsius i think
in
we're in the period of time but you're
right i mean like the [ __ ] was years
ago and
these things happen in cycles you know
people kind of forget
i mean look it's still worth a lot
bitcoin right now is worth 20 000.
that that's that that's a lot
yeah and it's easy to forget but
early on in the run of the show
uh in you know 2017 early 2018 was the
last time that crypto was having like a
big blow-up moment or whatever and
people were freaking out because bitcoin
was up to
think it peaked at like 18k or something
so it's actually still higher than it
was before the last crash yeah in 2020
i'm looking at it in 2020
it was worth about 7 000 throughout the
year
so it's still way up that there's still
way more money in this yeah
but last time
there wasn't all of these like [ __ ]
coins like that's kind of like the new
thing i mean some of them did exist but
you know the the level of
hype and investment going into all these
so
let's click mike's uh
a partner
app and let's see what kind of [ __ ]
is it says calculator let's see
the calculator it's just a normal bank
wait this has nothing to do with nfts
the way they make money is just interest
and you lock up your nft so if you can't
pay the interest they take that's the
collateral right it's just like a bank
yeah but that's the thing is like so
he gives them his stupid monkey jpeg and
they give him two hundred thousand
dollars
and then the whole market crashes and
they've got collateral of this monkey
jpeg that is definitely not worth two
hundred thousand dollars no one would
ever use that as collateral right well
so like what incentive does mike
actually have to pay it back i mean
unless he really likes it that's what
i'm saying too i mean how are you going
to enforce a crypto
can you do predatory loans with crypto i
mean it's just
what do you what do you owe me you're
like yo you owe me this virtual money i
don't see a court enforcing that
you could set up smart contracts i mean
that's a way to get the money back i can
choose interest rate
that's the best part
i can choose my interest rate what does
that mean well so you want to borrow
some money how much interest do you want
to pay
five low as possible okay good choice
what about if you were lending will
interest you yeah why don't you lend
them some money
that's the you see that other let's lend
them money so so this is the celsius
thing by the way
so let's say i'm gonna give you a
hundred eighth that's a hundred thousand
dollars yeah that's crazy you know a
hundred eighth used to be like five
hundred thousand dollars right yeah
uh choose your interest what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
well i'm gonna lend them
yeah twenty percent i mean if i were you
i'd lend it at like a hundred percent
okay so it says
oh the duration okay so let's say nine
months
okay check this out here's how you know
this website's a total [ __ ] scam
i'm lending them 100 each
i still don't understand what the [ __ ]
i mean it's just a calculator so maybe
it's just for argument's sake and why
60 interest rate
yeah i mean why wouldn't i loan my money
to them in 60 interest
it's a good deal
i i'm just i'm so confused
is anything changing in this when the
percent changes
i'm going to guess that you just lock in
the money for a longer period period of
time okay so
if you do 60
if you want 60 back
it says yeah in nine months
right in their calculator the longest
duration is nine months so these are all
short-term loans so in in nine months
you can get 45 percent return
and you can make 63 000 on 100 000
investment in nine months
money glitch
yeah i know it's money duping
glitch i'm just duping my coins
yeah so this is a scam this this this is
in this is the same thing celsius was
doing it's actually even more egregious
um this this is just an outright total
scam they're going to steal your money
for sure or it's just
going to go under
what i mean effectively they're stealing
yeah they'll go under with your coins
yeah exactly yeah i mean again that's
just the calculator so i mean i i doubt
you would actually get those interest
rates but it's kind of funny to me that
they even you know give the 60 options
like who's giving you 60 on a loan
if we do 60 percent
i'm so confused by this calculator
though i said they're they're just a
middleman it looks like their
peer-to-peer borrowing system where they
trade nfts for coins yeah i mean yeah
effectively
but i don't know about peer-to-peer that
would mean that there's somebody an
individual not the company on the other
side who's no they're not going to give
mike 200 000 that's [ __ ] if you loan
money it goes to them
there's no period up here come on i mean
they definitely get a caught either way
yeah
no they they're gonna hold the money
there's no way they're just passing it
to someone else that'd be mayhem that'd
be chaos
well
i mean
how the [ __ ] who's going to do that any
payback
no i mean they give money to someone
else it doesn't specifically right
they're a banker
yeah peer-to-peer means you're lending
someone else the money
right right or or just that's what every
bank does they
give they
use your money in the bank to give
people loans it's our own business model
right i guess maybe they're
saying
it's actually
direct person to person rather than like
i understand what you're saying it is at
the end of the day right yeah well it's
not to person-to-person
um anyway so mike shield for this
straight up uh scam
so shout out mike
but the other funny thing about the
board apes that i've watched
i watched that whole video by the way
though
nazi club i actually i didn't i i don't
have it in the doc for today because i
thought it'd be interesting to talk to
hassan about it tomorrow because there
is definitely a political slant to it
too but if you want me to grab that real
quick so we can shout it out um yeah i
want to hey let me pull the board ape
nazi club
this guy
made a video a youtube video
that i really recommend everyone watch
is by this youtuber named phillian
and it's called board ape nazi club
and he basically lays out indisputable
proof in my opinion
that this whole board ape yacht club
is like a straight up nazi dog whistle
it's crazy dude
it's indisputable let me show you some
of the basically
this is the main like this one is is
undeniable look at the watch this part
here okay
there's so many connections but there's
a few that are like wow that's
undeniable watch this part here
prussia because that will play out later
when we examine some of the bored apes
both logos also have 18 teeth if you're
unfamiliar the alt-right white
supremacists and neo-nazis love
that care
hold on it's the exact day that hitler
and board bia club was launched on april
30th which is the exact day that hitler
died the launch of board ape yacht club
was actually on the 23rd with a
week-long pre-sale and they sold out
before the 30th however they made it a
point to tell the new yorker that it was
the 30th i have shown this picture to
various artists this is board ape yacht
club's main logo that they use across
all of their branding and social media
accounts not too bad right how about now
most of them laugh uncomfortably in
sheer disbelief the audacity to do this
is mind-blowing it does not take a
genius to see that this board apiaclup
logo is a direct copy of the toten cough
the skull and bones represents death and
was used by both prussia and nazi
germany as a military emblem
representing death heads i only mention
prussia because that will play out later
when we examine some of the board apes
both logos also have 18 teeth if you're
unfamiliar the alt-right white
supremacists and neo-nazis love
alpha-numeric code the number 18 is a
symbol of yes so
the logo is clearly
there's no alternative explanation for
that is there
no it's obviously inspired by it and
yeah i mean he sort of lays out the
argument that um
you know it
may be that the people behind it are
neo-nazis or maybe they're just [ __ ]
4chan trolls that think it's hilarious
to you know
ironically be super racist or whatever
um either way i mean the end result is
the same i don't think it really i don't
know i think you have to be or not
i think you have to be racist to do this
because
well let me go further down the rabbit
hole
so the name board ape
yacht club comes directly from there's
this saying in the alt-right like nazi
uh people that originated on 4chan
it was called um
okay surfing
this this was blew my [ __ ] mind
surfing the kali yuga you've heard that
right which that's actually
uh
not related to the board a
name itself but it is i'll show you why
to the name of the company yeah i know
but right so i'm getting so anyway
surfing the kali yuga
is a phrase that's been used by like
nazis
and white supremacists on 4chan
uh the kali yuga is like a phase of
indian culture like the dark times and
they're like just surf the kali yuga and
pre embrace being the bad guy
and so they go just surf the kali yuga
or whatever
so this is a known phrase
yeah and it's all super anti-semitic and
racist
so the name of their company is yuga
productions yugo labs yuga labs
that's way too
uh specific and then the other thing
that blew my mind
is that
there's a telegram group
in 2019 before board apes was made
called
it was a well-known group called cali
yuga surfing club
which featured alt-right anti-sjw and
nazi-centric memes
so listen to this kali yuga surfing club
is literally
the
inspired it's like the same
or a board eight yap club by cali
or i'm sorry yoga labs yeah i mean cali
yuga surfing club board abe yacht club
so like
um
it's kind of weird it's crazy how the
links that they went when you watch it
um wait i just realized how he responded
to me on twitter
look at this
yeah it's crazy the links they went to
to
pull this off
and they have explanations to like they
go oh yuga is the name of like a zelda
boss
and he's like dude that's like the most
obscure boss in zelda ever
but it's obviously racist dog calls and
i actually found the whole thing
disturbing this thing of them being like
uh ironic
racist [ __ ] posters didn't really buy it
because they're just so intimately aware
with this whole alt-right nazi
neo-nazi
memes and stuff i don't see how you can
understand all that
without believing it really disturbing
stuff
i said
how he tweeted out makes me squirm
and then i said let's go
and he said
uh
howie
said
bro you tweet a lot
let's go where so there you have it guys
me interacting with highway
let's go
it's fun never mind
what do you what should i say go just
say it
go for it tell them i have a certain
building in mind
that and i'll just say let's go to the
nra
don't do that why are you suggesting
that it's a joke as a joke byob
oh my god
bring your own booze i got yes right of
course
i like chaos dan
says one since i get a week off
[Laughter]
so anyway
um
it's really disturbing
and then you get into the whole thing
with the apes which is like super
racists i mean let's be honest and
you're like well maybe it's just a
coincidence but
it really is just racist
it's so [ __ ] up i think uh you know
wondering the point that he made which i
think is is valid is it's
you know one thing two thing maybe three
things you can write off as a
coincidence or as a stretch or whatever
but this dude lays out
a lot of connections like almost every
single aspect of this entire project has
these
embedded messages and uh all kind of
stuff um
the one that i actually found the most
slam dunk because it's so
it's so specific is um you know all of
the board apes are numbered and 14 the
ape that is 1488 which is the uh you
know sort of nazi yeah you know dog
whistle uh of note
um is wearing a
jumpsuit with like the
year that uh who was it it was like a
famous nazi who was in jail um
eventually died
in that year uh and so the fact that
um
you know that particular
number
has this sort of
nazi further nazi iconography contained
within here it is ape itself it seems
this is the board ape number 1488 if you
guys don't know 1488 is like
uh
the 14 is
kyle
yeah the 88 is heil hitler yeah h is 14.
and the 14 is the the 14 words which is
sort of a message about uh that white
supremacy
so this is
so this is the board ape 1488 and he has
a jumpsuit with the number
19019807
right and so 1987 was the year that this
famous nazi died in prison and is sort
of like a um
a uh
icon amongst uh neo-nazis he was okay i
thought that one maybe was a stretch
because like lots of people die in
prison
yes but again the fact that you have
multiple nazi references in the one that
happens to be 1488 i mean it again and
this is on top of logo looking like the
ss symbol and all these guys having
coded names for neon like so that was
the point in the video that i was like
all right yeah that that seems hard to
what i was going to show you guys next
is like these are the four founders
and each one of their names is not as a
nazi dog whistle and he explains how
like each one of these names connects to
some [ __ ] up nazi [ __ ]
and he also shows that they're super
into like cryptography and [ __ ] and they
had this elaborate puzzle
so where you had to like decipher codes
for a for a prize and this is stuff that
they do which i think he did a good job
of proving that this is all
intentional like in cryptography
apparently you get rid of the zeros so
it says 1987 but let me see
1987
nazi i don't know let's see what happens
was his name rudolph hess it sure was
okay interesting so it is a thing yep
wow that's crazy
yeah dude these dudes are sick and it's
really [ __ ] up that like all these
celebrities and [ __ ] got uh what the
[ __ ] we got so many gifted subs which by
the way ruff s wasn't just a nazi he was
the deputy fuhrer he was you know
essentially
second in command of nazi germany so
so yeah you guys should watch the video
it's super
super good i'm sure it's mature rated
because there's like insane
content throughout right also also they
drop a f-bomb like second five and i
always cringe when i see users do
creators do that they just don't know
you can't say the f-bomb in the first 30
seconds right just wait wait a minute
nobody knows that
yeah youtube should say that
but yeah you guys should watch the whole
thing it's a fillion and it's like
people really need to know
he's a great creator by the way i you
know it wasn't until because he doesn't
show his face in this video until very
late in it and uh
it wasn't until deep into the video
where he popped up that i realized we
actually knew him because he's done a
lot of exposes um he was the one that
did the big whizza expose
um
with the elk boys fake fake
ferraris and stuff dude this guy's great
yeah he's not out to him he makes some
great content
so
this is a really important video i feel
like and uh
it just
it's crazy how everything in the crypto
space is either
a straight-up scam predatory and now
you're looking at the board eight club
board yacht a club where the [ __ ]
which is like the big successful thing
that you think about on crypto and it's
all literally nazi dog calls like
[ __ ] nazi dog calls and they've built
a whole empire they've tricked
celebrities
into talking about it i mean the whole
thing is just embarrassing people just
got
absolutely
it's it's it's it's disturbing and it's
disgusting and like i really think
people need to know more about this
company
it's so [ __ ] up
um
dude this guy gave
this guy uh members go up wait is this
the same one he changed his name
holy [ __ ] one
two three four five six how much do you
give 100 100 oh my god thank you very
much for gifted subs
subs members go up my dude
yeah he's
making good on his name
oh legend yeah we're a guy
so i don't i found this whole video you
should add like leaderboards for that
kind of stuff yeah like twitch has that
where like um
isn't that a plug-in a third-party thing
no it's just built in on twitch i went
and
a b was streaming like a week ago and i
went uh and saw that zach was his number
one gift suburb or whatever i was like
that can't stand so i gifted one more
than you zach so i took the plate on abs
on abc's how much should zach give to
you
he gets it like five and i gifted like
six it wasn't like
the boys supporting boys yeah that's
right
sorry i think i'm number one on
loves
now this is a good race for a b
you're right
yes
second i have a
deal every time he does that i i shout
out his song yeah
well
you scratch my back
yeah
i'll do it for freeze actresses
so anyway there you have it it was
really disturbing and i hope more people
watch this this whole crypto space is
just [ __ ]
horrible from top down
and uh
that's crazy
that's crazy this one
what the [ __ ] psychos dude
there you have it
what else we got how long we've been
going
two hours 40 minutes
let's see
oh let's watch the keemstar one we
waited okay now we're at the end
everybody knows what we're here to do
so keemstar
is butthurt that ninja
uh took his
uh g fuel flavor
cotton candy as you guys know g fuel and
keemstar parted ways
which was tragic and horrible the first
time anyone's ever talked to a sponsor
by the way
yeah and uh you started that whole trend
you monster
i still feel like that whole thing was
silly so silly nobody's ever lost a
sponsor because of shitty things that
they've done until
you broke the seal
well what was so funny is like
him and a lot of channels so many
channels were defending him just for
that so [ __ ] dumb even like obviously
even critical made a video being like
ethan [ __ ] up she shouldn't have done
that i love critical but i was just my
point is that like that was an opinion
that was
echoed throughout the youtube space
and they're like
youtube is gonna change forever now when
creators get in beef they're gonna call
out each other's sponsors and ethan's
open a can of worms and it's never gonna
be the same fast forward like three
years nothing [ __ ] changed nothing
changed because it already was
it was already like that obviously and
always has been nothing [ __ ] changed
like
i didn't ruin youtube see you guys three
years later we're all still here we're
doing fine
it's like god it's so annoying how they
i feel like they all miss the [ __ ]
point
but anyway whatever uh i feel like i
barely called out the g fuel thing too i
thought it was just funny it was funny
yeah
thank you dan
but okay whatever so he lost his g fuel
sponsorship some would say because of me
he would he would definitely
and he had the i guess highly coveted
cotton candy flavor now what does it
mean that that's his flavor love you
probably have an insight on this was
that his idea or did they give him the
cotton candy flavor
right so as a g fuel connoisseur i can
answer this uh
so every creator gets to like the g fuel
pitches a couple flavors and they get
get to pick it and i guess keemstar
picked the cotton candy
uh i actually have it right here the old
og one and it's honestly my favorite so
i'm very glad it's back that's what i
hear is everybody loves the cotton candy
so i have a feeling that keemstar was
making quite a bit of money
certainly from that cotton candy one
yeah but keem even if i even if that
never happened i mean let's be honest
the ninjas gonna make them a lot more
money than you i mean
hold on zach
you don't deserve the cotton candy one
anymore oh yes we have to he keeps
playing that sound but there's no
context what is that that's the point
dude that's supposed to grow man it's a
crime it's a little to not show this
video it's a little inside joke we have
around the office about ninja we all
stand nina oh
yeah
i think it's time for for you all to
come out of the ninja closet right now
this is full of of nina stands so i love
ninjas
since love came to town
yeah so can't so cam made this
[Music]
what is she freaking out about he uh
he's he's it's promo for his master
class
and what
[Music]
[Music]
what preceded this or
i need the context of this
i'll get the actual contact yeah i just
want to see
he was just excited like
[Music]
clearly
like i don't even know
but ever since love came to town in the
states and he like expressed his love
for nina
that's all we talk about is nina and
don't even say ninja we just say nina
el nino anemia yeah love says it so it's
like
it's [ __ ] a ian sam abe like everyone
just stands nina
we get together in fortnite we all put
on the ninja skin
you know that's awesome
it's rough wait can you talk in game in
fortnight yeah so you guys should just
dress as ninja and just make this sound
can other players hear you no they can't
hear you just oh you can imagine them
yeah that's sad they don't let me play
with them anymore because i didn't get
the skin in time i did love that about
pub g where you could talk to him oh
yeah that was yeah yeah that was great
dan
maybe i won't out dan for this
what that i'm not a ninja i'm i'm the
i'm the hold out here i don't even play
fortnite and i stan nina
um but dan just i don't know he's not a
fortnight stan nina dan hilter hater ass
[ __ ]
i don't have any problem with nina i
have a problem with fortnite it's a
little baby game okay
so i wanna show us a thing oh is this
called speaking of comments
it's pinned tweet still to this day
wait this is keemstar's pin tweet or
cops yeah oh this was okay
if this is what i think it is this is
this is one of the great
uh videos
and another thing you did in this video
is an absolute first for youtube
you went after my sponsors you went
after my sponsors today we're going to
be looking at soar gaming now sword
gaming isn't there like crazy slurs in
this video
closet oh yeah you're right yeah no no
no no no no no no no he's right don't
play this
well i'll play up too but you guys get
what you guys get words he says the
unalive word uh he says he's racial
actually yeah he's as the effsler a
bunch yeah n-word yes
something nina would never do man i
don't know we stan nino right love
yeah i want to show something though if
you guys don't mind check this out what
do you got
the doc oh that's what it is
tumblers
yeah shaker but this is a rare one
because when you flip this
look at this look at this read the dock
right boom
what does it say now dog [ __ ]
yeah
wait does he know it says that
no he's not on purpose it's an accident
that is awesome
how did you discover that
uh i think like it went viral and i well
i have that and dudes
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah uh what was i talking about i
closed my browser oh yeah keemstar being
a [ __ ] baby
so
anyway he's mad at ninja because he got
the cotton candy flavor
and he's he's mad because ninja
uh
didn't tell him beforehand because he
thinks they're friends keemstar i think
because he's an orphan he
has like deep abandonment issues i'm
just assuming i'm just making educated
guess here right
which is why he gets so
i think i'm really identify the issue
which is why he gets so crazy
when he
perceives people as like backstabbing or
leaving him or going behind his back
because he was abandoned by his parents
where's your daddy
when someone like me leaves a comment
like um
where's your daddy
uh he doesn't know probably
probably don't know where he is
but um
he probably has abandonment issues right
so when i someone like me leaves a
comment like oh yeah i know you guys
don't like keemstar i don't either he
freaks out because he perceives that
as oh he's going to leave me he's going
to backstab me and it's actually really
sad because i think
it really goes to
a really unfortunate deep-seated
trauma which i get you know i mean
i i really do sympathize with that
experience of his because i mean
that's just so sad and horrible
and so i think that's what happened with
ninja
that ninja didn't grovel the keemstar
for the cotton candy flavor he has a
total meltdown watch this
everybody agrees with me right ninja
steal my flavor he's a wrap for that but
to the few people there definitely
everyone i get it right now just to
remind you this his partnership with g
fuel ended like three years ago yes
and so ninja gets his flavor three years
ago
and this [ __ ] after three years
is now like this is my flavor you should
have kissed the ring i mean it's nuts
everybody agrees with me two years right
ninja steal my flavor he's a rat for
that but to the few people that are
thinking i'm being petty i get it right
you're right to look at this on the
surface level and be like keemstar is
just being petty i get it you're right
but you don't have the context all right
i've been friends with this dude since
2017. every time he's in drama every
time the internet is mean to him and
over the top not being fair to him i
stick up for the [ __ ] dude
i love when keemstar admits to [ __ ] like
that
which is what i've always said about him
which is why i've always thought he's a
piece of [ __ ]
is because if he doesn't like you he'll
lie he'll slander he'll try to ruin your
life i mean really make your life hell
and if he's friends with you he won't
report anything bad that's going on and
like he's news i mean it's just
it's it's just disgusting behavior and
it's he's always been like that uh he's
been on my podcast
i
didn't report when when bad things
happen to you and you [ __ ] owe me
i'm still not even sure why he's been
it's been two years bro two years
well let's hear him out because
apparently everyone agrees with him
everyone so
he might have a good point here all
right i'll stop pausing as i you know
i don't know
i've been tight with ninja forever
the fact that
you know
he goes the g fuel and says i want
cotton candy because like look look the
manager his wife and him are looking at
this and they're like okay what flavor
should we do what makes business sense
and because my fans have been asking for
my flavor to return cotton candy forever
they're like okay let's just take keems
now
wait did they discontinue cotton candy
love once she got yeah when he got
oh they stopped selling the flavor
yeah that's why this is very very rare
right here oh interesting so there's
been a cotton candy shortage yes so they
brought it back with ninja basically
that's going to go back to the full
version
it's a variation
so it's not even exactly the same flavor
right they brought back the cans
not the actual powder which they're
selling in walmart
yeah i gotta say
i i've never wanted to drink more in my
life
and
i called like five walmarts yesterday
he's not goofing he really no no one
could help me ninja
we're all in the blevins brotherhood
here
like this has to be more accessible
was it sold out or did they not get it
yet none of them had it
yeah
he was serious he was working you gotta
roll those out man this could be a huge
partnership ninja x g fuel cotton candy
right in every walmart we could be
sipping them right now yeah and it's a
shame we're not it's a [ __ ] travesty
you know it's a real travesty
that we didn't reach out to g fuel and
get the cotton candy flavor now that
well to be honest right after game got
dropped i did reach out to g fuel for a
partnership
and what's funny is they were they've
been hitting me up basically my whole
time on youtube
and i just thought it was so weird to
partner with g feel like i was like i
don't i don't get it uh maybe i should i
probably should have
uh they're popular talk to them but i
always thought it was just kind of odd
and i don't really drink that stuff so i
don't know klein kiwi flavor
kiwi climb kiwi climb that's pretty good
yeah but after this happened i was like
yo let's partner up now
like maybe maybe not yet yeah
yeah but maybe we should reach out again
it's been a while let's get that cleaned
key we gotta be so awesome dude we could
probably still get the powder versions
oh right there would it be i said you
just fed the drama channels i'm curious
of the thumbnails wait what did i say by
saying that you reached out to g fuel
after keemstar you think so we talked
about trisha who cares about you feeling
gives a [ __ ] yeah
they already have their
lights yeah nobody pays look i'm excited
to try this klein kiwi i think it'll be
good wait how did i contact them before
hold on let me write an email we gotta
get we gotta get on this deal
[Laughter]
are we dead set on kiwi
no it's just
coming up with names ah i see strawberry
kiwi why you got a different idea uh key
lime i'm thinking klein
flavor
tea flavor do you feel interesting
here i think she's asking is g fuel even
good it depends on how you ask if you
ask love if you'll say absolutely lovely
loves that he only lives on g fuel i
tried it when he was out here he he
hooked us up with some and um
it was one of the sweetest drinks i've
ever tasted in my life
it looked really sweet it was very
[ __ ] sweet gamer fuel bro you know
love got me hooked i was it's a little
too sweet for me but i understand why uh
people is there no sugar in it love
yeah no sugar oh ethan raspberry
somebody suggested
i like that
ethan raspberry
i'm eating raspberry
love was my
g fuel somalia when we were living
together
he showed me the perfect amount of uh
right to put in it yeah yeah the right
amount to mix he was the best you think
martin knows [ __ ]
love about g fuel yeah he is the man
what is that sommelier yeah
face up
face up
ethan klein speaking pesto
oh no all right i just wrote an email
that we're very we're very passionate
about g-fill and want to get it going we
could sell a lot of jeep fuel
yeah
i'll move g fuel like they never [ __ ]
seen
would you want to be in a walmart with
it like nina or like just an online
exclusive i'm direct to consumer yeah
did you ever
did you ever see keemstar as gpool
commercial
oh yeah
we made it he went to the carnival
yeah yeah
yeah we did a funny edit of it back in
the day yeah
never forget making that content nuke
though with
we were in the trenches man with the ian
and
and god it was so long ago were you you
were with us you just started right i
just missed it
oh really yeah they were like
it was it was just uh ian
myself and zach i think wow
ian was in the trenches big time was a
heavy lifter on that i mean we all
contributed but ian was like pulling
all-nighters on that me and ian were in
the uh laboratory quite a bit on that
video trying to connect the dots it was
a masterpiece
thank you very proud of it
i wrote
one of my greatest songs i feel
keemstar nibble on your cheese oh yeah
of course of course right right only
recently surpassed by
holding my burden
holding my pardon i love that that that
was a bop i wasn't thinking i'm singing
it all afternoon oh here we go
here play that as we watch game stores
do you feel ahead yeah
[Laughter]
ninja should take this and just put his
face over keemstar the whole video
keemstar would go to a carnival by
himself i know this is so sad this is
some sad act [ __ ]
you don't have one damn friend
it works so good
good let's get it
what kim yeah
sorry
were you going to say something though
it the song just works so good oh yeah
it does it does
he was daydreaming the whole thing i
guess that's the concept but it wasn't
that
you don't need to daydream going on
carnival right i mean he was already
there it's not like green you're
literally there yeah go just go do the
things that you're fantasizing about
yeah that was a huge loss for kim the
cotton candy thing was big
he'd continue ninja would have came to
me and said keem
can i bring cotton candy back i'd be
right it's been two [ __ ] years it
doesn't [ __ ] belong to you yeah it's
g fuels flavor dumbass you didn't make
it
you stupid ass this is so weird
to even put this video out is so
unhinged like yes you have my blessing
you're my homie go ahead rock it rock
like that he would have the full
blessings but that's he doesn't need to
kiss your ring what don't you understand
god leave me he wouldn't why would he
even think to ask that totally after two
years yeah or even even not it's like
i mean i don't need the i don't know the
logistics of how it even happened they
were probably like yo do you want here's
options of flavors like what love said
and he's like cotton candy
what do we think
well doesn't he say at the end of the
video that jessica reached out
let's let's keep watching
it's not what happened okay
ninja didn't say [ __ ] to me his wife
contacts me and says hey we just a woman
you know that uh we're we're launching
uh a cotton candy can
all right that was actually really
thoughtful i think that they gave him a
heads up yeah and it's not just yeah but
his wife is his manager right right she
she's he's offended ninja himself didn't
yeah oh ninja's wife yeah she's a woman
you send your little messenger
that's awesome didn't say [ __ ] to me his
wife contacts me and says hey we just
want to let you know that uh we're we're
launching uh a cotton candy can so they
did let you know like what the [ __ ] do
you want
they literally told you ahead of time
which was way more than you deserved
all right they gave him a heads up but
didn't ask permission again to sell a
product that he does not own
two years after he got two years after
he got dropped what is he the [ __ ]
dawn or something yeah he thinks he
really thinks he is
didn't [ __ ] ask for my blessing she
didn't ask for [ __ ]
you come to me
on the day that i lost my final hair
and you
you don't ask for my permission to sell
the cotton candy
i sit here bald before you
with the bandana tightly fastened on my
head
i'm losing
oxygen to my brain from the bandana
tight
and you have the balls to send a woman
to tell me you send your brother's wife
to me
you said you said
you send your brawless wife and when she
came she was wearing a bra
if you're gonna send your wife to me
make sure she's not wearing a bra
and make sure she bring a sandwich too
show me some respect i shouldn't have to
ask for the sandwich
it should be unasked for
you
ninja
you breaking my heart
the cotton candy flavor
it's my flavor
i know it was you freedom and how dare
you send a woman
be man enough to tell me yourself
i keemstar
i'm taking the cotton candy flavor
just like i took the teddy fresh
and i sit here before you and you've got
this long beautiful blue hair
i have not even single hair on my head
ninja
and you disrespect me
let's help
[Music]
spongebob squarepants movie played again
[Music]
jesus
that's interesting did you pull that
just for that image
uh i i forgot what else we were talking
about but uh i don't know i felt like it
could be funny yeah yeah
justin
yeah so she just [ __ ] told me that
they're doing it right this is like
weeks before it was announced
and i'm like dude i'm gonna [ __ ] say
something that that's not [ __ ] cool
i'm gonna [ __ ] say something
so i'm like you know what i let it i i
calmed down for a little bit i talked to
many other [ __ ] creators about the
situation yo i was so heated up i had to
calm down
talk to a bunch of creators i was having
a total [ __ ] fit i was on a podcast
with 12 views asking all those creators
they all agreed with me as usual
everyone agrees with me literally
everyone i talk to
who they everyone who owes their whole
career to me agreed
you're in trouble that g fuel [ __ ]
i was [ __ ] that was good sounded just
like him everybody agrees he's a rat for
it and i'm like you know what let me
talk to ninja himself so i call this
dude multiple times no answer like so
ghosted by nature
you know what's the truth team star that
i called him man he's not answering
nobody takes my calls
you know what's the the uncomfortable
truth keemstar is that
that i think you're you're afraid to
confront the truth that you really
lost all your clout i think he is famous
and toothless and
not many people watch dramaalert anymore
and i don't think ninja has the time to
or the interest
uh to answer a call from keemstar i mean
there's literally no incentive from the
people probably after
his wife got bitched out by keem yeah
while trying to do something that they
totally didn't need to do politely
inform him like he said weeks before it
was announced that hey this thing is
happening yeah
why am i owe you anything no but yeah i
mean people i'm sorry keemstar but i
don't i think the days of people
answering your calls is is gone
you know what i mean it's like i'm so i
just i don't know it's like nina is like
vito corleone or jessica's like vito
keem's more like a fredo type
he is
he totally is we gotta take him back on
the on the lake
he's like alfredo and you know you just
i don't know nina's
he's the dawn be careful with the fredo
though that is italian phobia oh i did
not mean that's an offensive phrase
forgive me i did not read it like that
rolled that bachelor roll rolling it
back did not mean in any way i was just
comparing to the movie that i was making
and thank you for that i'm sure everyone
will appreciate that that kind of just
made me sad after re-watching that i
think keem just needs like a good will
hunting like it's not your fault type
hug
it might it's a hug i actually agree
and in all honesty
it's not your fault his upbringing
sounds like it was really difficult and
yeah
um
it's keemstar's fault no it's not it's
not it's
it's not your fault
it's keemstar's fault it's not your
fault it's not your fault keemstar it's
not your fault no you're not listening
keemstar
it's not your fault keemstar's fault
it's not your fault it's not your fault
no but on the real though i i feel like
he really could benefit from therapy i
don't think he would ever pursue it well
we know not he stated his opinions on
that very publicly yeah three sips of
beer that's all you need but here you
know
i feel i do feel bad you know
and kudos to him for bringing his or
giving his girlfriend the childhood
upbringing he never got
that's true you know
and it benefits both of them because now
they've got to uh
he has someone with him at the amusement
park so he's not alone anymore
say that i'd be i said it benefits both
of them too because he's not alone at
the amusement park right right right
right they have that
yeah that's a really good point you make
cameron you know he's paying it forward
yeah
it's not your fault
oh boy
cam really got me with that one it's not
your fault game i really i actually do i
really do think so keemstar's fall it's
not bro it's not it's not your fault
it's not bro
it's really not
all this [ __ ] here i love that scene by
the way goodwill and thinks such a great
movie one of the best he goes all this
[ __ ] here well i want you to know
something
it's not your fault
he goes i know i know
no it's not your fault it's not your
fault
go ahead put it out man cut it out
go ahead put the
the keemstar one keemstar's fault
no no no
you're not listening
uh it actually it's too real it's too
real it's still on the nose yeah
keemstar's fault that's such a great
sound but holy [ __ ] it's not your fault
all right let's
[ __ ] you [ __ ] that blue haired freak i'm
dying
i hate him i unfollowed him and
unfollowed his greedy little [ __ ]
wife on everything why is he again he
goes after his wife greedy little wife
what did she do it sounded like he said
it's not like he said grady
she said greedy little wife let me play
who haired freak i'm done
i hate him i unfollowed him and
unfollowed his greedy little [ __ ]
what did he say it's not greedy
crazy did he say crazy
crazy okay wait wait let's let's let's
listen carefully
i'm done
i hate him i unfollowed him and
unfollowed his greedy little [ __ ]
gravy is it just
sounds like grady what is great it's not
he's grady right like just grady he
definitely said grady but maybe he meant
to say greedy and just got tongue tied
grade e
grade e grade e
low rating they look to be to be there
are examples of him mispronouncing words
write him right on drama dramaalert
dramaalert
homophobic
hobophobic
it's like a romeo wait so i'm saying i'm
trying to look in the chat people are
saying grady but that that's not a word
is it grady
everyone's saying grady
i think he meant to say greedy that's
the only thing that makes sense
gravy was he trying to combine crazy and
greedy in a way
maybe grody
gross doing some like valley girl sling
it seems like nobody in the chat knows
what he said to so it's not just us
i'm done
i hate him i unfollowed him and
unfollowed his grady little [ __ ]
grade e could he have said that raid e
oddly enough i think he just misspoke
but if he did say something else i think
it would be great e what the [ __ ] is
like he's yeah he's rated girl she's not
even pretty dude yeah pokemon's a
terrible man sorry is it two out of ten
according to him
that would be crazy if he said grady but
i feel like there's a there's that's
unlikely he rates on a on a numerical
chart though not a uh
true alphabet or a scale so that would
be inconsistent i think i think that's
great
the best theory i'm seeing is great
crazy plus greedy he got confused and
combined them that's what i'm thinking
yeah maybe
and he just let it go freak i'm done
i hate him i unfollowed him and
unfollowed his greedy little [ __ ]
wife on everything when next time you
guys are in trouble don't ask for my i'm
not gonna help you [ __ ] off it was so
disrespectful to do it the way you did
it
yeah
aka now when i report the news i'm going
to do everything in my life to just
everything in my power to destroy your
life
number one news source on the internet
yes number one trusted news in the world
we got your back ninia don't worry yeah
don't worry
i'm just looking at his twitter joe
biden is the worst president i've lived
through i mean
that's facts that's a bit hyperbolic
66 agree everyone
agrees well how many has he lived
through well his audience has only lived
through writing so well he's lived
through at least like uh
15 right uh he would have been born
during the reagan era um
so you know you got reagan bush uh
clinton second bush
obama trump well what is he like
no he's 16 he's 40. 45 right so there
you go i i put it at the back of the
show cause you know whatever but that
there you have it a little bit of a fun
uh
keemstar update for you guys they're
good very good and that's about it isn't
it
that's about it we've been going
310 here
look at them go just let me see love
again let's go
you're a little delayed love you got to
speed it up beat it up speed it up
faster faster
there it is it's like double there it is
you're locked in yes
[Applause]
are you tired love
oh my gosh
uh love you honestly it's hard
can you yawn like that again okay give
me sir
i might be honest
all right thanks for watching everybody
it's been a fun episode eh yeah it's a
good one thank you everyone for tuning
in
thank you to all the
people who have donated and are gifted
members subscribed we love you all thank
you to
mikey our new uh
political correspondent yes
and thank you again about the howie
thing thank you guys for all the really
nice comments on there that was that was
awesome super nice
very heartwarming i really was i really
appreciated it
right well we'll see you tomorrow
morning for leftovers and then on to our
usual friday after dark so have a good
week guys we'll see you
or have a good evening and see you in
the morning thanks guys
oh
[Music]
oh
oh
oh
oh oh oh
[Music]